today is uh we have a guest and we're
gonna talk for a little bit before that
like always just what you like
today our guest is the great rosebud
baker she's a comedian with a new
special on youtube it's called whiskey
fists that is a great title
mine would have been whiskey ovaries
might have been whiskey tits
but to each his own she has a podcast
with her husband andy haynes it's called
find your beach if it was my past
podcast it'd be called
find your bitch
i truly love rosebud but before we get
to rosebud baker we have a little talent
show for you as you may have noticed
here at good for you we have a team of
talented showboats constantly keeping me
humble by rolling their eyes at
everything i say and shooting me with
nerf guns since it's clear they're
starting to feel starved for screen time
we are going to do a recurring segment
where our gaggle of thespians dazzle you
with performances that require a
delusional amount of courage
i decided
to stop wasting their brilliance on
things like emailing and scheduling
the things i actually need to function
in society and start putting them to
work as child stars so as their momager
i will start building their careers as
future cruise line theater actors by
honing their acting skills but before we
get to rosebud let us blow you away
with the good for you teams mind
mind-boggling impressions
who's up we're doing me doing an
impression of somebody who cares
so
i
i have noticed that everyone that that
is on this podcast is weirdly good at
impressions
uh like excellent at it
i mean you will see none of those
talents in the next 20 minutes right but
they she means other people
no it's mostly well a lot of our
impressions of people that we
like and we're not allowed to do those
they're our own friends
so there's a lot of impressions of
people we're not really allowed to do
but
i have one good impression and you think
that that means i have lots of good
impressions i only do one person as well
and i cannot do anyone else like it's
comically bad but your impression is of
someone that decides who's good at
impressions and then my thing is true
that wait kim do you think we can say
who it is i just do a really good lorne
michaels because you used to work with
laura michaels and i just do a really
good one and then the way i do
impressions is i just tell you how i
hear the person
and it has nothing to do with how they
actually are it's just my in my head
version and you for something to get a
real kick out of it because the essence
is right and no one commits like a one
benton ray hickerson like when benton
to do impressions you have to be really
fearless you have to get in the arena as
brene brown says and you the key to
impressions is committing to it you
can't be like i'm kind of doing this and
you
just completely disassociated you're
doing it now then you can kind of do it
uh and this new segment is called
burning bridges uh so benton you are
going first right yeah and we're gonna
start with me being all of our uh good
for you
fans okay you're doing an impression of
our fans in the comment sections
okay comment sections haven't watched
the episode yet but lots of interrupting
i'm sure
have you ever thought about doing this
podcast completely different from the
way that you do it i know you put a lot
of work into this way but what if you
did it completely
this episode was really enjoyable but i
do have eight complaints
i love whitney as the host it's weird
that she talks though
hot
it's my impression of um good for you
fans leaving voicemails
hi whitney um uh
whitney this is crazy um whitney
um hey guys uh um it's me i just wanted
to say that i am oh my god this is so
crazy um i am a fan uh
you guys are like stupid idiots um
listen no listen i'm gonna leave a
voicemail stop listen no um okay so uh
you guys are fucking stupid um
i'm gonna call back i'm gonna call back
hey whitney and brandon
um
are you are you gonna listen to this
wait are you gonna listen to i'm gonna
call back if you're gonna listen to it
i'm gonna call back
hi whitney and uh benson and the whole
good for you gang um i just want to call
and let you know that um you're
pretty fucking hot
okay i'm gonna go it's so true
oh my god that is
that is disturbingly on point i know
i did a lot of research that is a call
to action to our fans they don't know
our names our jobs i don't know anything
about them hello benson
no one's ever got my name right great
show i have eight complaints
so true i haven't even watched the
episode yet but i feel like winnie and
her absolutely weird that she talks love
whitney is the house but weird she talks
are these youtube comments mostly
youtube comments and the voicemail ones
that was specific to that day when i was
watching voicemails with emily and i was
like this is insane you did there was a
day of voicemails that you got that was
particularly bizarre i mean i'm like
you're not even saying world was that
like a holiday or like cinco de mayo
maybe there was that was like a day i
just said what no one believes anything
was it mother's day like i feel like
there was one day where the voicemails
were all like off like a disturbingly
like we should have reported them they
were crazy but a lot of times they're
wonderful yeah there was a string of
them we should go back and see what
holiday that was i feel like people
might have gotten drunk and lonely
fourth of july and taking it out on me
mm-hmm i feel like we need to do more
stuff with the voicemail so people know
how much we listen to them because right
now we don't do enough with them because
they're all so crazy but they're all so
crazy because we never do anything with
them right right stop calling and
breathing to the phone
it is a lot of that it's just
it is stop yeah watch porn oh no i know
but i want to start um or maybe we
should take live calls or something so
people know we're going to answer
i know a lot of them are cries for help
i feel like a lot of these voicemails i
don't want to hear them because i feel
like i'm going to be involved in some
kind of court case and i like i'm just
like i don't want to know i missed a
whole bunch of people you should be like
here this al in my yard and it was like
yes yes people would ask this question
remember all the advice people were like
i have a girlfriend and i want to take
her on a date where should i go and you
were like anywhere now it's all just
like evidence in a crime yeah
now it's all just like drunk people or
like horn dogs it's all just guys i just
bought three shovels at home deep oh
yeah i jizz on all of call me back or
else i'm gonna do it like what
huh i'm gonna mail you my pubes what's
the address like i'm not telling you
i did say on the june show that i did
want someone's pubes to make a merkin
out of it so as soon as i list the
voicemails i'm like this is crazy and
then i'm like oh i i i have a partner
that's like the time you were on age
three and said you like dick pics
that was the most traumatizing year of
our lives yes i went on h3h3 and i was
like i love dick pics i love looking at
the background i'm obsessed with
people's decor what better way to look
at people's private choices in their
bathroom than getting a dick pic i like
looking people's towels i like seeing
what kind of deodorant they use i'm like
mitchum i forgot about mitchell yeah we
had people dipping their nuts in ramen
noodle bowls and shit it was crazy
just people sent a pair of their sis
like this is like a sis i don't know
where are doctors what it was gross
frankly i would be more into balls if
they tasted like ramen noodles the hot
take
to be fair what flavor beef to be fair
shrimp shrimp always
yeah shrimp ramen the best the little
tiny shrimps i like the veggie deluxe
there's no way any of that is shrimp no
no those are not products
something's sitting near a shrimp yeah
anyways let's go to our next one which
next impression is emily performing you
being you but again i'm not good at
impressions okay this is an impression
of emily
i'm sorry this is emily i'm doing an
impression of me right now always i'm
always doing impression of that girl
whitney coming uh but emily is doing an
impression of me
no one knows me better than emily am i
gonna get canceled i like to get
granular are we friends
june shine
emily you can't even aim
that's about the nerf gun oh my god hold
on just i'm sorry this is already this
is so funny first of all emily is in a
blue wig electric blue she's wearing an
electric blue wig uh we left her blonde
hair peeking out because who knows the
next color oh no she's wearing a shirt
that someone from i think like malta
sent me
it's a shirt that has a red soccer
jersey with horses of king with my horse
on it i still don't know who sent me
these
whoever you are thank you
uh they're insane she's wearing a large
turquoise horse necklace no that is a
necklace
yes that is the turquoise horse i
thought it was the wolf and then
the gold horses around and then she's
wearing a necklace with no less than 12
giant uh gold horses you're readers i'm
wearing chester the molester blue light
your blue light glasses
are those oh here they are right here
she has her june shines out in front of
her and she had an open bottle of grape
seed oil emily almost killed the cast of
friends
all right now i'm rubbing lotion all
over my face
is this etsy she doesn't do that etsy
package benton also likes to keep in
parts where i'm
like i love
i it's honestly it makes the impression
that much better because then we see
your real personality and then you go
into character
is that a dog where's my dog that's my
dog mona
i'm not doing it like her mona
where's my phone
i have a phone necklace hey whitney let
me just tell one thing one thing one
thing let me tell you one thing
one thing let me tell you one thing let
me just stop you for one second let me
just tell you for one second i want to
say uh i'm literally right now going let
me just stop you because i'm realizing
the most genius part of this impression
of you arguing with benden the best
impression of me is just arguing with
benton for real
so it's actually when you're arguing
that that is the best impression of me
that's so true
okay now
i'm
with mona and i'm eating magic spoon
with a fork
he had me driving to brentwood
that is
a joke that she made me leave it in i
don't know if anyone even gets this no
no when i did a talk show for e
scottie landis the great scotty landis
hilarious writer that wrote on the show
i was dating a guy that lived in
brentwood at the time and it was my
first talk show and i decided that every
i was doing a podcast right i was doing
a podcast ironically now you're doing a
talk show
this is by the way had i put the effort
into that talk show that i put into this
podcast and hired these people it would
still be on the air um and i would
be in debt because of of what tv now
pays but the point is yeah magic spoon
wasn't around then um but i
i was like doing really inside jokes
like i was like no i want this to be a
thing if you get it you got if you don't
you don't like if you like i wanted it
to feel like this and um there was an
inside joke in the writers room about
how i had to leave
uh uh after the shows and the guy that i
was dating lived in brentwood and i was
like i got in and he was a very toxic
person really bad for me
horrible relationship but i'm like oh he
lives in brentwood and i was like is
that
what you think the problem with this
relationship is
so it was always like like what i missed
because i my br i tend to miss the point
sometimes like something will happen and
i'll have just the wrong place it will
be on fire and you'll be like no one
picked up the dog
like true like truly yeah so people
would be like like how's the
relationship going i talked to my
therapist i'm like it's just that he
lives in brentwood and everyone's like
that doesn't break the top 200 things
that are wrong with these bruises you're
like but
i just tried to break one
it was which by the way isn't that far
away it's brettwood is just like a
suburb of l.a
and the fact i wasted a lot of time in
that relationship because i i was like
well if we just we're driving if we just
move in together the listeners like we
get when this joke doesn't work now yeah
like we understand why he wanted to take
it out of the show so there was this
metaphorical thing of like oh does he
live in brentwood like it was like it
was just like an inside joke okay i
don't even get it now that i'm talking
about it i don't get it either i get the
joke i had a huge crush on scottie
landis yes and like every year and then
we went on a date and i got so drunk i
had to sleep in my car but
that's neither and that was just you
last week that's neither here nor there
um
wait i'm gonna do an impression of emily
noonan i love you
and then the valet was like ma'am
ma'am
and you say get out of my room like what
are you calling me
how did you get in here you pervert
that's emily in the back seat of her own
car stop hiding on my window
well look if you want to cut this out
later that's fine but i do remember
emily we worked together and then she
went and worked on some other shows and
then she came back in this capacity and
i remember being like
you know you should go on a date with
you know you know like i i cannot
believe
i've never put this together you're like
i went on a date with them you're like
yeah i got so drunk that i fell asleep
in my car
and that was so frustrating because i
had a crush on him since
i worked with you like he i remember he
left his sunglasses
in your house and i was like i cannot
wait to get those sunglasses back to him
and then like three years later you just
gotta keep on hoping he asked me out got
so drunk was asleep in my car at the
valet station did you by any chance
drink a margarita that was 56 percent
proof or whatever i drank won the jen
kramer episode last week i wish
i would have rather behaved like you on
that date than the way i behaved and
then do you remember it no i don't all i
remember is like being he left hours
before i did i just sat at the bar
and then i got in my car and then what
if he didn't see you get that drunk are
you sure
he was oh yeah because i've never like
heard from him again and i i saw him i
saw him like at a fourth of july party
and it was so awkward and i i just can't
imagine how bad it was you didn't talk
oh i tried to talk to him because i was
also drunk
so he thinks you have a problem drove
away on a boat
he got on the hydro gotta go
she's so drunk she's like
she won't know this
is there's a pirate i'm swimming
by the way he just like jumped in the
pool you're like he got on a boat like
there was a pool what boat where were
you we were in mayorga we're in newport
oh okay at a fourth of july everyone's
always that's a drunk place
newport beach california yeah it was at
adam devine's house
and when he was on there was a boat when
he was on the podcast i was like oh my
god i hope he doesn't remember me i hope
he doesn't mess with me
i gotta tell you
oh this is also this is not making me
realize from this video and this you
tell me that all of us have this weird
lead-in to things we don't want to say
whitney is like let me tell you one
thing and then you're let me tell you
something and i'm always like first of
all
okay okay no emily says i have something
to tell you and then yours is first of
all first of all let me just say
even if it's the fifth or sixth thing
always first of all first of all
and then you might argue with first of
all
well i'll also go can i just can i can i
one second can i just can i but let me
touch you up i'm just looking because i
don't want to lose our train of thought
so that's the bretwood joke and i
believe that was worth it that was a
worthwhile tangent this is my new
impression of emily every emily's we've
known each other for how long now
like
nine years
nine years uh was in a personal
assistant capacity in my home for
speaking of cockroaches i was there for
three years
that was a call back from last week's
episode when i drunkenly
called everyone cockroaches and sprayed
dry shampoo at us
so
raid cockroaches are actually very
resilient creatures
they are resilient they've they're they
are uh
you look old but very wild they're
ambitious they are they are teflon they
have an exco skeleton that is very
they're going to survive the apocalypse
that is a compliment
they come out at night they shit in your
home yeah
you try to experiment my impression i
don't know if any of the cameras even
every day emily comes in
into the office
since she's had she literally i know she
i know you're in the room i hear you
coming in the dogs bark and then i just
see like
around the corner like come in you're
like hey
like what do you think i'm doing what
are you afraid uh like are because you
could knock
like do you want to catch me naked it's
weird to knock on wouldn't my own office
door
but what do you mean
but you don't just go like hi
like i just turn around i see like why
because you could be your forehead i'm
like what are you doing
i don't know if alex is here i don't i
don't know i did tell you i did oh i
this is my fault
so over the um this happened over the
pan you know i mean my new thing with
the pandemic is drop the charges
everyone lost their minds right everyone
lost their mind in the pandemic right so
i'm not gonna qualify why i said this or
did this it was the pandemic we all lost
lost our shit so uh we were together uh
once it's also weird because we're we're
legitimately very good friends like if
not best friends so it is really hard to
know where the line is it's true we're
just waiting for our necklaces it is
really hard and so
um so we were talking i really injured
my left ankle
giving a blowjob in a closet
in december
i was i had had covered i was not
i my hair i my hair
my hair looked like a bunch of french
fries i was just like there's no way i'm
gonna keep this man i'm gonna have to
give him a blowjob at some point and
we're in a closet and uh i like went
down and i don't go on my knees i'm an
adult i have aldrich slaughters i can't
and i was like so i was like i was like
well because to me a blowjob now is like
you just do it for and then it's like
okay now we can right right you're not
going to keep doing that
yeah
yeah yeah i have a fractured l4 we're
not we're gonna this isn't gonna go to
the end we're not going to you know i
mean right so um uh i can't i can't go
more than 30 seconds without talking
how am i going to how am i going to be
able to suck a dick for uh any time
until it's
cooked till it's done
and so i went down like in like a squat
like a cat like um catcher yeah and then
i was trying to like change angle i
don't know what i was doing
and i i heard a pop in my left
ankle
and i definitely like strained something
and i couldn't like work out for a
couple months whatever and it just it's
too weird saying like i have a blowjob
injury like it's just too
insane you can't say that to people
right but we were driving so because we
work in a closet that's why you're
nervous no we were at this different
house and um i said to emily i was like
oh yeah and i rolled i rolled my ankle
one day you know you were telling zyde
we were on yes and we were trapped we
were in texas like we were like drinking
they're drinking yeah and you were just
like talking
i was talking to someone else and you
heard it oh yeah that's what i said i
was like oh i rolled my ankle giving a
blowjob and emily just went was i there
well that's not as bad as i've walked in
on her
me you and alex no that did i yes i did
that was a long time ago someone said
take my wait by the way
hold on i've never heard this story i
yeah because absolutely didn't happen
i'm a great this has been this is like
literally a year ago yeah or year and a
half this happened so long ago what
happened right before i thought it
didn't happen i i thought that it didn't
happen i i truly thought that i made it
up in my head because you not bringing
it up why would i do that that's all
right oh my god i'm sorry i'm sorry
there's nothing you and i don't let me
just talk about it why it's crazy okay i
because i am it's very rare that i get
uncomfortable i'm actually uncomfortable
crazy because it's not like i had left
for the day i was sitting on a test
daisy was attacked and bleeding from the
face and i sat with her at the
while the vet was here i went to a
different vet and sat in a parking lot
for three hours with daisy while we
waited to get her stitched up and then
when i came back to drop her off
as she runs up the stairs
i i go into our office which just have a
mattress on the floor and whitney goes
don't come in here i'm already in here
i'm already in the room davey's here
we're all here wait in the room that i
peek around
yeah the office yes well that used to be
kind of be a bedroom it was nick's room
it was nick's room my friend nick we had
a bunch of mattresses on the floor and
we would just always sleep
you knew i had to bring the dog
but here's what i'll say here's what
i'll say and so i just closed the door
on home here's what i was okay so benton
turned
faster than the woman that walked in on
you in the bathroom at the airport or
walked down backwards i went
no but ben didn't it was it was actually
wild because it was like i was like
there's no way he saw anything if he
turned that fast because you literally
like
like it was almost like you were in
anticipating it on some level but it
happened so quickly because i remember
being like oh yeah this is my worst
nightmare and alex was like no there's
no way oh my gosh that alex is like
there's no way he saw it he just walked
into a room and immediately left no but
it was just my whole
i didn't care about that do you remember
what configuration literally my whole
brain was like
so she wasn't upset about the dog
i could have just left the dog here she
i didn't even need to take it it felt
like it was a panic in a big situation
and where we really needed to make sure
daisy was safe
you were just wanting to hoard our
personal vet
for doggy style yeah i'm like so me and
daisy are just like just she's just i'm
just holding a tissue over her face in
the parking lot i just need to get you
two out of the house yeah i was like did
she attack daisy
who hurt davey for this oh my god oh
this is the one she got stuck by the bee
no it's just whenever um
uh that squirrel whatever the hell she
bit her face remember right here oh
that's it through her lip and it was
just like we had to get her she did get
shots and it was like it was a big deal
and i was like we might i must go
and whitney was like see ya
peace but yeah here's another thing well
how do you think i paid for that vet
bill
wait wait you why would you're paying
for it if you're paying for it because
she was
getting it i was emotionally paid okay
the fact that someone walked in on you
in that room and you still ask me why i
peer around like a little ghost that's
why
i don't know what's going on in there
cold
you were sick i mean you had a bronchi i
remember we just went like all these
doctors together and i was like what in
the world yes the only time i have
consensual sex is when i'm in a bunch of
nyquil and decline antibiotics yeah i
was like she can't breathe the dog is
hurt
i'm i'm still on the clock i'm like
what's happening
i'm like this is great i mean it was
like
one in the morning but it's just a
biological clock that did
i was like get me pregnant bet it's gone
for three hours this is my healthy shot
and i was like what and then it was like
don't come in here we're already in the
same room
we're together in the room
this is now a three-way you have to stop
did you see his butt or him naked
he was laying on the bed well you know
what's funny is that's not the day
because okay so our office right now is
in sort of an uh i've seen alex naked
twice now oh because once when we were
at the of the rental house
uh wow this is when you started you had
you had accurately i think had coveted
and i was sitting at the table and i was
doing work on like the oils i was
arranging all the boxes and alex got
home and he went in this room and then
and then you went to take a bath and
then he came through naked and saw me
and then backed up and i was like i saw
you i saw you
why are you walking the whole house
thinking you know we're all working here
oh that house was just bad news nothing
would make it worse than something i saw
you
you know i'm like i see everyone
the only thing weirder than seeing this
naked guy is seeing him cower as if he's
invisible like now but now it's weird
that's what i would do you covered
the emily thing first and pete but
didn't see me and i was like what is he
doing and then and then he was thinking
i was like you're naked
you should have looked harder i'm at the
dinner table i'm like hello
hello
i mean it's crazy
first of all you know i'm here
i live here
we live together i was like
i didn't brought that up either but it's
actually they're very good at retreating
i don't think they could be i'd
i did not
i did not that's my trauma know about
that because if i had covet i was right
off the rails well he clearly didn't
bring it up either i know but yeah what
was he doing naked when i had coffee
what was happening what happened when
did he come into the tub with me i have
questions i think he was going to go in
there with you and he was peeping to see
if anyone's still there taking any naked
baths with him during i'm sure there's
only fully clothed
i'm just saying well i guess a lot of
stuff happened that i don't recall we
need to we should
put that on the better help list we need
to add that but i was like i've seen you
naked more than i've seen myself naked
jesus there is okay so we're uh the
addict has like a little bit of a slant
you know and one time we were
fooling around on one of those
mattresses that were on the floor and
you came up the stairs and i was like
yeah like because i was like
and he
went up and hit his head so hard
on the attic ceiling which you did like
yesterday remember right now but like
what are you guys 14 i know but i was
like this is our office i know
this is literally our corporate office
what if it's mad men we're
sex in the office
well we are drinking weed drinks yeah i
was gonna say
why don't we uh why don't we just do a
break the trauma
let's burn into my eyes i'm litha kudrow
in front of my eyes that's me oh gosh
you need to do a new impression reel of
me emily now that you know all this yeah
we need only fans but listen we need to
update this impression you know the
weirdest part of this is that everyone
now we all know that we all knew and
everyone's just like all these moments
like hello anyway so we're just we're
what do you have the emails for today
like what were you doing in here i don't
i i don't have sex in that office and
now that it's anymore now that's because
she don't have sex
anymore i don't
yeah exactly right now that i'm sober
and youtube i don't have any sex but no
uh
uh that is now an office there there are
more there's a standing dust in there by
god no more boning yes now there's a
girl in their 20s here it's dangerous
yeah yeah it's a dangerous work
environment they know how to tweet
they think things aren't supposed to be
toxic they have standards so we had to
pull it together around here oh we have
another impression nobody ever told we
just never discussed that by the way i
truly did it here i was like by some act
of god he didn't see that like i thought
he just walked into a room and
immediately there's a hallway
and i was like oh maybe my first task
for you was organizing your own photos
i've seen so many things
oh yeah you and joel my i.t guy we
literally he goes in and does my um
every time he goes to do my hard drive
stuff for my
icloud security like he won't make eye
contact with me for like two months
because of the news there's nudes i'm
like don't you worry alex i've seen all
the x's naked at this point don't you
know oh no they're all in there
we need to delete those by the way
wow that wasn't part of my job i was
supposed to organize i'm so much more
embarrassed about like the screen grabs
of like princesses really embarrassing
what i was doing the language of letting
go like a daily meditation reminder
none of that bothered me i was like this
is all normal human things but like all
the pictures of your shoes on your feet
were weird you just have all these
pictures of you in different tennis
shoes from a long time ago and i was
like what was she doing it would be you
at an airport taking a picture of your
shoes you're in a bathroom taking a
picture of your shoes i'm like is this a
fetish or a cool shit one of my brand
new sneakers yeah like they were like
that like you were trying to look at my
designs
it was so weird that's so much more
embarrassing than anything
i was like nudes more than merrier i was
like shooting pictures yeah i was like
shape-up
was i like trying to be like look at my
cool kicks that's what it felt like it
felt very like the beginning of
instagram people were like
netflix
jordans and i was like what the fuck is
happening
let's go back to the titties i cannot
wait to read your book
it's gonna be so good i'm a loyal
trustworthy great person it is actually
going to be so if i wrote i'm trying
really quick if we wrote books about
each other what would they be called
emily if i wrote a book about you or
like like a tello
oh mine would be called brave brave
if you about me oh it's going to be
called brave
i want to reach out on my book the naked
truth i'm just saying i just mean about
walking in on you naked all the time
mine is gonna be called mine's gonna be
because you worked at last and now
mine's gonna be called live from
brentwood and
that's a mix about both of our terrible
relationships
but you uh just really quick emily
people do think you're sad and hot we
make jokes
people have crushes on you i'm sad
people are in love with you people have
offered to pay seven thousand dollars to
watch you give a wedgie this whole sad
rigmarole
time's up it's embarrassing
you are you have a wonderful life people
want to date you people like you
and you
you cry at
you do cry a lot but it's when you watch
like you're about to cry
like it's not over guys or being sad
she's not it's like over my nose
it's over like racism
like i see emily cry she's like the
video machine took my dollar it's like
that you're like what yes there's
another dollar like it's like the things
that you shouldn't cry about you're
really into emily got two episodes into
your honor and i thought she was gonna
die of dehydration i was like this is a
dangerous amount of crying
and she was like but don't you think
this really happens in the world i'm
like yeah i think that's why they wrote
about it she's like
no
emily almost started crying when she was
drunk once talking about reebok
and i was like i actually understand
this
i do cry a lot i'm a crier like right
it's i when i
i cry one time i go how to cry without
looking like you're crying and it said
to look at the ceiling oh yeah no that's
the whole you just lay down i have a
video of it remember yeah but that's
still to like not mess up your makeup i
was trying to find a way to cry tears
without anyone seeing them i always just
say it's allergies oh okay and then it's
everything
all right natasha bennyfield oh next up
sorry we just went on a real tangent me
being uh the one and only natasha
bettingfield icon herself icon legend
star and natasha bettingfield
oh
to describe what you're wearing for
everyone oh i am wearing a green beret a
blonde wig with bangs i bleached my
eyebrows
i'm wearing this 90s lip color that i
googled that she she that's what i'm
wearing right now she did an article
about like that color she wore like i
have that um in like an old interview um
a lot of blush because she's happy i
have on a new turtleneck and some pearls
and a bright neon blazer and i think
that's pretty natasha but honestly it's
pretty amazing i could have shaved for
this but i didn't wait what is this hat
with the bumble is that a bumblebee
that's my um shit's creek hat i wore in
our costumes
it's like an olive colored
beret
now he's writing
and the rest i'll leave on racing
that's me trying to do that i can't i
don't know what her accent is so i'm
just
now you're looking at books
can you believe all these books have
been written
completely written dark in here good
thing i have a let's see i have a um in
my pocket oh some sunshine
my pocket full of sunshine nobody worry
what do you have in your pocket
hold it wait for it
can i explain what i'm doing
what i've in my head what if you're
watching it what i'm doing is these
songs these really positive songs you're
playing and i'm like i thought it was so
funny if i was like what if she was
pissed the whole time i'm bored because
she said to sing this song
and then and then this is her new song
and i like what if i like transition
like that's a great song but here's my
new song and like did this transition to
the new song but it just reads like i'm
just dancing alone it really pissed the
pocket full of sunshine is genius that
is a stroke of genius that was great
thank you i like the rest of it is a
spiral into insanity
look at all these books they're written
so funny
one of them is mine so easy i'm like
visually this would be so funny that
she's so mad but now you're just
listening to her music you're just
listening to her oh that's a great
impression and i don't think we're even
allowed to play it no no no no i cut it
to where it's supposed to be chunky
enough oh good i think we can i feel
like when it gets point watching and i'm
like i don't know
in my head i was like oh this is so good
so quick but now i'm like oh god am i
still dancing to this fucking song
you're in a music video
this is so embarrassing it's still going
it's still going
my whole impression i'm just performing
the song what is this what what happened
i ran out of things to do i think that's
all i noticed i can do with her and so
now i'm like but i love natasha so much
i want to give her a good video so i'm
just like this is your song's fun that
doesn't feel like a private moment
no about windows everyone can see i'm
just saying this feels like it's like
something you were doing for fun for
yourself yeah yeah this it feels like
something we're not supposed to see yeah
well try i want someone to see it okay
great just keep watching because i'm
really enjoying this
oh over here's what i'll say benton i
know you walked in
i know you walked in on me having sexual
intercourse
but i was not as bad i walked in on you
making that music video for yourself you
know i
i brought that to you as a gift i i
literally as soon as it kept singing i
wanted to turn it like around very
quickly i feel like i wouldn't me too i
feel like i witnessed something very
intimate after the impression that's
what i'm here for to connect with people
okay that was beautiful it was it was no
that was thrilling that was that was no
it was truly insane i mean i was like i
was in my head i think oh this is like a
minute but i love it because we should
keep doing this because it's like it's
not necessarily about sounding like the
person or like
whatever but also the joke
it's just about playing their music
karaoke yeah dance around no but the
jokes that you did are brilliant mm-hmm
all three
they are that is hilarious to me i want
to keep doing these and i want but i
also
the next time we do them i want them to
have some kind of um like topical
relevance and then we can talk about
topical things that's good like like i
want you to do listening that you're not
relevant or topical no i'm so oh
don't do people like whitney cummings no
no these stale impressions of shrill
whores no i want you to do elizabeth
holmes because i want to talk about her
i hate that everyone says i look like
her that is so don't look at anything
like her you're just blonde hair and
blue-eyed
and we'll just throw a black turtleneck
who's saying that who's everyone that's
telling you that my friend ben
fucking ben is he just everyone now so
we're gonna start doing more impressions
if you guys have specific impressions
you want us to do we will take
suggestions uh but you should also take
suggestions from benton's impression of
you guys leaving voicemails and comments
just know that you we're watching you
we know you got your number we got your
number two you have our number so text
me eight one eight two three nine seven
five two seven uh you can send ideas
there leave us voicemails eight one
eight five three eight nine nine four oh
email us at good for you fans gmail.com
what impressions do you want me to do
what impressions do you want emily to do
what impressions do you want benton to
do
you're our lorne michaels enjoy rosebud
baker another blonde hair blue-eyed
cutie who's hilarious
and not
an airhead
or a cockroach
so this is exciting um rosebud baker's
here this is a thrill i'm thrilled i
started i'm so thrilled really yeah i
really am i haven't because i've been
watching you through the pandemic and
before that long before that
and so you did nothing you didn't do an
intervention you didn't call listen and
ask if i was okay i started to go fund
me and everybody said i was trying to
raise money for myself
you guys know this is real this is for
whitney's rehab
meanwhile you have amazing new hair
extensions i like seriously very those
are the real ones very expensive those
are not the jessica simpson ones no no
does she have her own
she used to but because i remembered uh
i was maybe 25 and i had 250 dollars
saved and they were like 240 dollars oh
shit and i make good decisions and i'm
an entrepreneur so obviously that was
going to be what i invested in even
though it was like a very different
color than my actual hair right uh and i
learned the hard way you can't apply
heat to them hers were prosthetic they
weren't real hair yeah so you use your
hair so it melted all over my body i
have applied so much heat to these that
they actually are as uh bad as my real
hair now like they are just as dead as
my actual hair sure
sure yeah as someone with incredibly
healthy hair um that is completely
natural i have no idea what you're
talking about okay i i did the last
interview we had has left everyone with
a bad taste in their mouth oh god
we'll talk about it later because i want
to talk about you wait a second
i have to ask you
i love it you're just coming in what
happened big rosebud i need to know what
it left a bad taste
it didn't i just okay here's the deal i
am
i'm the long story because i am
incapable of brevity or truncating uh
long stories uh okay emily i do need you
in here then can you come explain what
happened um you were just acting a
little bit like this like yelling at me
no passing me around telling me i was
gonna be alone forever i didn't say it
that way yes we have it i said where do
you have to go right and then you said
it's not like you have anyone to go home
to
i am your home though i am your host i'm
your home um we are full great i'm big
eating little lady you can't go home you
decide who's big edie and who's little
edie you're baby
is it skinny and fatty or just tall and
short i don't know
successful
i am trying to think get a plan b going
you know with uh like a partnership with
an alcohol brand i'm doing like
investing in companies okay a business
move because yeah because i'm gonna get
cancelled for being toxic by emily emily
will sue me right uh and uh who was the
snitch at um theranos the henry
kissinger's grand oh uh tyler schultz
tyler yeah she's gonna get a book deal
and my uh career will be over which is
fine but i'll have a backup i'm
investing in um
booze this hard kombucha company is it
called booze it's called june shine it's
hard kombucha but it's a slightly
alcoholic okay so it's the brand is
prickly pear margarita is the the flavor
that we made right
and then so i'm like such a dork like
type a like
even though i have no idea how to work
in the alcohol business i'm like i need
to like test other marguerite our
competition so we got these like little
margarita things yeah and i never had
one before and i drank it and then
we had these like thc things i mixed
them and then i started calling her
boyfriend a robot
well honestly
you know what it was
i'm so excited you're here because
what was my biggest qualm with her i
could there was nothing dark had ever
happened to her nothing bad had happened
to her and she was just so like like
together and i was like if this is
scientology like just tell me remember i
was like what's happened to you that's
bad like for real what's the actual why
would you become a magician right
something happened to you yeah did your
uncle make his dick go
disappear
inside you just tell me right and she
wouldn't no there was nothing and i i
think i couldn't attune to someone that
had no ostensible damage well it's hard
to trauma bond with somebody when
they're just like not when they're fine
when they're on trauma yeah i think i
had that uh happen to me
with uh trevor wallace i i did i did an
interview with trevor wallace on my
podcast and i was like that i quit but
my he was like fine
i was like any skateboarding accidents
anything nothing
no traumatic brain injury
i actually understand somebody who is
like mentally unwell better than someone
who is just really well adjusted i think
um but then eventually i get exhausted
by them and i just leave them to
themselves i guess for me it's like i
just don't know
how to do small talk it's no for me i
don't do small talk i'm trying to get
better at it because i i think that real
conversations come from small talk
like you get into important shit through
that sure but it's just really hard for
me to i just feel like
i just like you were saying i dissociate
while it's happening that's how let's
talk about that because well first i
want to ask are we friends what is our
the context of our relationship i know
it's the weirdest question to ask but i
cannot stand it when i go on podcast
something this is my best friend whitney
i'm like i don't know this person right
right and this now you're making the
thing awkward because i have to pretend
i know you better than i do and i don't
yeah you know like i just like to go
here's the circumstances you're walking
into you might watch us become great
friends right now but if we don't know
each other so people
understand right they don't know if
we're best friends or i've never met
before yeah so um
the facts on the ground
not yet
those are the facts on the ground that's
how i so facts on the ground not yet but
like i also feel
um
like we've talked a little bit yes we
both love animals yes we both love
saving animals and things and people yes
that's i know that and human beings in
the form of adult men right we're from
the same
place you're from virginia virginia
where are you from exactly i'm from
maclean so wild yeah so weird yeah so we
have similar backgrounds and every time
i've talked to you it's been very easy
like very well i think we both have like
this you know for me when i meet someone
that's in any kind of recovery or any
kind of having knowledged
sometimes my ideas aren't the best ideas
yeah yeah which is usually the common
denominators people who have either like
given up drugs or alcohol gotten sober
or had food stuff whatever it is anyone
that is seeking suck out
anyone that's been like hey
i'm not god right or hey sometimes my
decisions aren't the best it doesn't you
don't have to have ever gone past one
meeting ever gone past one therapy
session ever gone past one better help
set whatever it is is whether you went
to church whether you went into
scientology anything to go hey
i'm pretty sure i'm
not nailing it yeah yeah yeah like i do
need a little help here yes those two
are always the smartest the most
self-aware people or the most
interesting people because a lot of
times it is people whose lives are
amazing but just not good enough for
them and they don't feel like they're
living up to their potential or they're
just able to
be honest with themselves and
acknowledge the fact that they're doing
the same thing over and over again
expecting a different result or like oh
i heard someone right or i'm hurt myself
right you know i'm saying anyone who has
the ability to be that conscious is so
different than someone that's just like
i'm good don't need therapy no
everything i'm doing is i'm just killing
it on all fronts yeah
that false um
false confidence is like what i would
call it it's like there's this false
sense of self but that i do really envy
those people because they're so sure of
themselves even though they have no idea
who they really are but then
i am i feel awful for that i used to be
jealous like the idea of i wish i just
was a malignant narcissist or i wish i
would because i always have i asked my
therapist all the time i'm like my
narcissist just tell me she's like
narcissists don't go to therapy twice so
we can go am i a narcissist let's fix it
right narcissists don't go to therapy
they think they're nailing it yeah you
know or they go to therapy and they use
it to kind of my therapist said that
narcissists and psychopaths are uh the
best clients for him because they they
don't learn anything but they really
pass the message on to other people
very well
like he's like they get me more clients
than anyone else but i haven't been able
to make a dent in their psyche fantastic
because they're like you need to go to
therapy yeah and you need to go yeah
they'll sell it they'll sell it like
it's changing their lives but they don't
they're not like the no real change is
actually happening and so he's like yeah
they're they're amazing clients i mean
just in the sense of like for business
but they're not i can't help them and
they're not they're getting sicker
because the nars is getting sicker
because he's now or she there's such
thing as female narcissist hashtag
hollywood um but
you
are actively now going not only did i go
to therapy for me i know all these other
sick people in my life yeah you're also
actively criticizing and judging other
people and playing god yeah but there's
something so funny to me about everyone
that the narcissist sends to the
therapist is like a normy and amazing
yeah and have no problems yeah
the narcissist yeah yeah they're just
like uh there's so many broken people
out here and i obviously have i've fixed
so let me just help out yeah yeah yeah i
basically am just coming to you to
audition you yeah so i can send other
people to you right so my life is easier
because i have a lot of friends that
need to be in therapy yeah and they
won't shut up about me going i'm just
here to vet you yes yeah so that i can
send people over i mean that is so funny
it's like when people you know talk
about alan on which is a 12-step program
i'm in which is like you know we'll get
more granular about it if it ends up
coming up but when you're addicted to
people perfection control
the 3m smothering micromanaging
monitoring et cetera et cetera yeah um
and uh
usually when somebody qualifies and so
how do i know i need to be an alan like
do you think do you meet other people
that you think should be and they're
like oh my god you know who needs alan
on this person this person i'm like yeah
that's that's yeah you qualify basically
how much you think other people need it
right yeah and i i think i'm very guilty
of that like i'm guilty of that on
multiple levels i mean
when i got sober i was like very
interested in making everybody else
sober
so
i mean that alone was like pretty
psychopathic like i would be in a
bathroom with somebody snorting cocaine
two weeks sober being like you gotta
come to a meeting with me
and then like try your cocaine please
bring the yeah i need something it's
fine if you bring it it's fine you know
but i wouldn't even i wouldn't even be
touching it i would just be there like
it's important for me to be here right
now having no idea how i was deluding
myself as an actual addict by being that
close to a situation that was like could
have
just ruined everything that i had worked
for i think but though but to me that is
so um that is so rad number one that
you're of course able to see that but
the you know number one drug it's like
you know what they say about al-anon you
know al-anon are basically all of the
behaviors the self-medicating behaviors
that were available to you before drugs
and alcohol were right so that's why
they say al-anon is because we're also
the superiors uh the graduate program
because it's like after you stop using
your substance yeah then you have to go
okay what made me start using that
substance in the first place and what
behaviors was i doing before i was
introduced to drugs and alcohol i was
probably trying to please my mom i was
organizing my room i was over achieving
i was trying to control people i was
tearing heads off my barbies or whatever
i was doing so it makes sense that
usually right after someone stops using
their substance of choice which is the
thing that anesthetize them now it's
like i need to fix other people i need
to help other people because we don't
have self-esteem of our own we
essentially build our self-esteem based
on how useful we are to other people
right which is all bullshit and none of
it's real you're not really useful to
other adults if you're trying to solve
their problem you're just not giving
them the dignity of their own experience
and you're micromanaging them but it's
the same it's whack-a-mole yeah you got
sober from one thing it's like okay now
i need to fix everybody right it's like
um one of the
most valuable things that i learned
after getting sober and doing like other
12-step programs was just going oh
nobody needs me
like nobody actually needs me and
they need you to leave them alone so
they can learn to solve their own
problems yeah they're adults and like
the only people that really need you are
children and and anybody even them
anybody who even acts like they do need
you is a huge trap like a huge red flag
which we're going to get into but i do
love the idea that pedophiles are like
no this kid just needs me right
yeah even that kid doesn't need you yeah
that kid needs its own parent and to
learn consequences and to maybe get lost
and have that like don't even get
involved yeah any i am so because i want
to ask you when you got um when you got
sober you were very young
i was yeah yeah i was i was in my early
20s what was the um sort of moment you
were like this is no longer serving me
this isn't fun anymore it's no longer so
anti-climactic love it really it was
just so climactic i couldn't come one
night i lit yeah no that was actually
just
late for work couldn't climax anymore no
i i
think i started like knowing it was a
problem when i was just like running at
the edge of rooftops like blacking out
and being like somebody's pushing me but
then being like oh no i'm killing myself
again you know like that was the thing
that i did i started committing or not
committing suicide but like threatening
to commit suicide every time i got drunk
did you remember it
um i remember like moments when i would
come out of the blackout like
specifically literally thinking somebody
was trying to push me off of a roof
pushing back against
the person who was pushing me but it was
me running it was just me running at the
edge of my roof and then like my ex was
like across the roof like sobbing and i
was like you're so fucking dramatic like
i was just like i was drunk that kind of
shit
and then um but when it really like got
down to it i just
alienated everyone from my life that i
could have blamed for my drinking
and it just was me
on a on the floor of my apartment
like trying to cry to feel sad for
myself and not being able to because i
was like i just knew my own number i was
just like so full of shit yeah i was
just like you are so fucking full of
shit it was like i looked at myself it
was literally a moment which is a little
on the nose if you were writing a script
but i looked in the mirror and was like
you're so fucking sad and like i was
just like i got pretty let's figure this
out
this doesn't matter i was like what is
going on i'm sober i realized how
gorgeous i'm like god damn
i'm truly like i just decided that day
and i remember i somebody had given me
their number
while i was out drinking the night
before
offering an a meeting which is not what
you want that's not yeah i will need
triple-a
numbers when you're out drunk people
would give me their number and be like
come to a meeting and it was like i
would take the numbers so that i didn't
look like i was in denial sure sure sure
and then i did call this one girl and
like waking up that morning i called
this girl i had been training for a
hostessing job that had like eight
tables in it and i couldn't remember
which table was like it was numbered one
through four on one side four through
eight on the other and i could not
remember so like my brain was mush
and
i got fired from this job before i was
even ever hired they spent three weeks
trying to train me i'm pretty sure they
thought i was mentally challenged and
they were like doing and like doing me a
favor
as someone that has gotten sober off of
substance before uh i do believe
that
women that have not yet gotten sober are
why sexist stereotypes exist yeah if if
if any other reason then to get sober is
that you're setting women back because
everything we do when we're on these
dumb drugs plays into the mentality like
they're bad at math like blondes can't
figure things out it's like no i'm not
stupid i'm not inferior i'm just wasted
yeah i'm just just trying i'm hung over
okay if i was sober i could totally do
this yeah
truly and i like i i called this girl
that morning and i fucking i was like
hey i think i'm
i i couldn't say like alcoholic or
anything but i was like i think i'm
gonna i'll just i'll i'll meet you at
that meeting that you told me about and
it was in soho in new york and i went
and i sat across from the comedy cellar
at esperanto's cafe it was
yeah and i sat there and i waited from
like
2 p.m until uh 6 p.m just waiting for
that meeting to start and i
and then i went in there and i was like
oh and i just never had a drink ever
since
right what was the thing you heard
because when i first went to a meeting
and i think that for al anons like you
know the rock bottoms are a little
vaguer a lot of the behaviors as
al-anons are rewarded socially um we're
kind of the they're like you're an angel
you're so great you're keeping it useful
you're so helpful you're such a good
person because we're the martyrs right
right and we're the ones that come out
of relationships what i do without you
when somebody asks um
you know how did the relationship end we
normally answer with i just loved him
too much yeah he just couldn't handle
all my life it wasn't love you were
micromanaging you were manipulating you
were controlling so it's harder because
all of the things you're doing are
ostensibly kind nice things it's very
hard to be like you need to go into a
program you're buying too many gifts for
people it's a weird thing but in reality
what you're doing is you're making your
life unmanageable a manageable because
you're obsessing over other people's
opinions of you and the most insane
thing is that your insanity is you
believe that you can control it right
which you can't
it's like oh yeah no it was just that he
took you out to your birthday dinner and
then you snuck away and paid for it
yourself you're like you know what i
mean it's like that kind of shit where
you're like you're in two hundred
thousand dollars dead yeah
yeah like it's just it's the little
things and and you know to me i had you
know and i think it's important to say
that for alcoholism to be present
alcohol doesn't have to be present so if
you grew up in a quote alcoholic home it
could have been a mom that was obsessed
with cleaning or a dad that was obsessed
with being organized on vacations
alcoholism manifests in many different
ways alcoholic impulses addictive
impulses that i think can be no no one
to me addicts like you know and like i
know we're supposed to say the disease
of addiction i don't think we're allowed
to say addictive thinking anymore get
the fuck out of it by the way get the
fuck out of here why i was just
listening to an addiction specialist
talk about something and she was like we
try not to say addictive thinking
anymore because it implies there's like
a choice or that it's just like
ephemeral like your thinking goes in and
out but the disease of alcoholism is
because of the nature element of it
because our dopamine receptors don't
hold on to dopamine the same way
and that doesn't that still doesn't make
any sense to me i'm like why is that i
just don't get it i don't know but it's
the same thing we're in program when
people say character defects like people
like we don't say defects we say
superpowers i'm like fine i don't give a
shit i'm happy with saying it's a
defector it helps me it keeps me humble
it is a fucking d it's not a superpower
me going through guys phones like it
didn't magically make my life better you
know i thought it was a superpower
before yeah it'd be a superpower if i
didn't get in the accident texting and
driving thinking i needed to text that
guy back right away like i didn't fly
over the car like it's a limitation so
so there's i think sometimes i i push
back on those even though i'm trying to
be like gentle with the way i talk about
myself right people but um but i'm just
so curious because when i went in
it was very much like i'm going to this
so that the
the addicts in my life the people i
can't control rather the guys that i
can't control the females i can't
control them my mom i said whatever
i'm just gonna go so that i can be like
well i'm an eleanor like i just wanted
proof that i was superior and smarter or
better like i was like but i'm in this
program which by the way just because
you're going to this program doesn't
mean you're emotionally sober yeah or
actually obstinate or sober um but it
took me a while
to
think i qualified in there my ego was
like you're smarter than these people
you're busier than these people like you
don't have time for this your disease is
working my disease was working too well
for me at the time at least my
yeah magical thinking thought so right
and then i'm always curious the thing so
so one thing i heard
like six months in
and i was literally going because i
would see like cute guys there that i
want to fly like i was just like a mess
a danger
toxic and um this guy got up and he
shared and he went i have good news and
bad news the good news is the war is
over
but the bad news is you lost
right and i just like heard that and i
was like oh my god i can stop fighting
like i'm like it's fine yeah now i can
just start picking up the pieces i don't
have to i'm not because i was still sort
of shadow boxing yeah thinking that the
game was still or the war was still
being fought and i was just like you
know that that um soldier they found in
japan that didn't know world war ii was
over like 10 years ago they found him in
a cave and he was still like and they're
like they're like it's been over for 50
years he was like
what and he was just in a kid like such
a good comparison that's what i felt
like i was just like i'm gonna get you
you're not gonna get one over it's such
a funny trying to feed people to the
punch and manipulating and lying and
just doing all this stuff that served me
really well when i was a kid that was
like really toxic as an adult so hearing
that just
something crystallized but you just
going in there right away you're like i
get it yeah i think i got it before i
think i got it before i walked in and i
think that's the only reason i stayed if
i had learned it in there i would have
been like i gotta go home and process
this for a second but i had i had
literally had that moment where i looked
in the mirror at myself and was like you
are so full of shit and i never said it
i just like felt it i felt like every
part of me was just bullshit yeah and i
was right like it you know there's like
a there's a very different feeling that
you get from the truth than you do from
like almost the truth sure and
like you can you can feel that
difference and that was just like a
somebody like hitting this tuning fork
in me where it was like this is like
everything around
in my body was just like yeah you
need help like you are
out of your fucking league but this is
fascinating i've it's very rare that
that someone this is like a this is like
ninja like black belt recovery shit what
you're saying so few people are able to
acknowledge when they're lying because
there's so much shame there and that's
such a big part of program is like you
literally the medicine of program is
going in for the most part and just
telling the truth yeah telling you
because you're only as sick as the
secrets you keep and the more secrets
you have the more shame you have and
that just is what drives the right the
disease but you know it's so interesting
what you're saying because i think
comedians by nature are the people that
cannot
be full of shit like there's we have to
say the truth the awkward thing the
uncomfortable thing yeah we're all just
going to pretend this is a thing you
know like yeah
we have like tourette's yeah and so it's
so interesting to me when i think about
you know
just sort of like the overlap of being a
comedian and then
being full of shit it's like the it's
the worst thing you can be yeah it's not
like i fell off this thing or i hurt my
friend it's like i'm just full of shit
right and my whole thing is that i'm
supposed to be just obsessed with
justice and the truth right yeah it's
just so interesting that that's like a
comedian's rock bottom yeah it was like
this uh just kind of calling my own
bluff moment where i was like
i wish you know i really wanted to make
this work this like relationship with
alcohol it it it was like everything to
me i mean literally the first time i got
drunk i was like i want to do this for
the rest of my life
this is what i meant to do and it's also
like and you know i hear because i got a
lot of like double winners meetings and
at least did in the beginning and it's
um double winners is like if you qualify
for more than one thing or if you go
into allen on because we are para
alcoholics we call it which is like
don't mean to brag but al-anons we do
all the same crazy shit you do yeah
sober yeah so
well
that's what drove me there that's like
why six years into sobriety i was like
oh
shit
yeah because my life got like way
way it was it didn't get worse but it
got
way more painful
like yeah because you could feel
everything you can feel everything and
i've been on the side of an alcoholic
who's like
just running somebody else's life kind
of like making their
i mean i was the center of their life
but and i've also been someone who is
in a relationship with an active
alcoholic who's sober and i'm gonna i'm
gonna say it right now like for me
it's way fucking worse to be
someone who's in love with an alcoholic
than an alcoholic who is like letting
down the person who loves you
because at least you're you're only
conscious for half of it that's right
you know but the problem is but when you
get sober
you feel
10 times worse than anyone you know what
i mean yeah like you know so it's like
putting off that inevitable like the
more i found myself when i was in active
addiction with a substance it was like
the more i was letting this person down
the more i had to keep doing the
substance because i had to uh put off or
delay the embarrassment the future
embarrassment and the future shame so it
was just like that would just build more
and more and it's like it's like that's
why when people in relationship with
active addicts the best thing you can do
is just leave them so that they have a
consequence so they stop hurting you so
that they can get sober faster yeah jim
saying because the more they disappoint
you as much but also if you're staying
in it what's going on with you and your
martyr thing why do you need to number
one be with someone that's emotionally
completely unavailable why do you need
to in order to feel useful uh uh try to
fix this person maybe they're not broken
right or maybe you're not the person
that's qualified to fix them maybe it's
out of maybe you're not bad but also
are you addicted to adrenaline so that's
a big one for me that was like a like a
mind-blowing thing when i learned about
epigenetics and how you can basically be
born addicted to adrenaline the same way
uh like a crack baby i really love to
call them that um
it is born addicted to crack like if
your mom produces a lot of adrenaline in
the womb because it's a stressful
environment it's a hectic environment um
and you're born addicted to adrenaline
because adrenaline makes dopamine so
people that gravitate or actively engage
and really you know people just always
have chaos in their life yeah and you're
like you're so smart you could solve
this like you could just leave 20
minutes earlier right and not like i'm
like i'm running away like right there's
some people that are so addicted to that
that they create when people uh watch
reality shows to relax i'm like how
why
why i've never watched them i don't like
them i'm not like i think one thing that
i really
over time because i think i've been in
recovery now for like 14 years
um and it's like
over time i've really just like i don't
want any i don't like to have things be
chaotic i mean my schedule would say
otherwise like the things that i do
with work i'm starting to like examine
that and i'm like oh that's probably not
the best um like what
like over scheduling shit overdoing
things physically tiring myself out to
the point where i literally have nothing
left to give to
um the people in my life you know
um and the relationships that really
matter like my family and stuff i don't
um
i just have nothing left for those
people and it's like i i know i'm doing
it on purpose on some level i really
know that i'm just like
trying to avoid those relationships by
filling my life with work so that i can
be like oh you know what i can't
i'm so sorry
but do you want to see them
not necessarily well if i wanted to i
wouldn't um
because here's here's where we're
available you know here's my thing i
also think that we
sometimes uh and i don't know you that
well but sometimes we over pathologize
like you know work addiction is very
real but also like
you have a special out right now yeah on
youtube now is the time no yeah i'm
sorry like if it if it ends up being
like diminishing marginal returns or
ends up not being in control or whatever
you can't say no or you're getting sick
or your immune system but it's like
there are with what we do there are
times that we have to be so sober in the
way that we live when things aren't
hectic yeah that when things are hectic
we're able to go hey dude you might not
hear from me for two weeks like having
people in our lives that don't take that
personally that don't take umbrage out
of that don't make it about them yeah
that that um know like this person
taking care of themselves is not a
rejection of me that's a narcissistic
injury yeah that's i mean that's
completely that i would say i would see
that as separate from what i'm talking
about where it's like i am filling my
shit my schedule with like shit that i
don't need to be doing you know what i
mean yeah shows i don't need to be doing
that that's right gigs i don't really
where the money's really not that good
and i haven't seen uh anybody that i
love in a long fucking time that what's
your logic when you do it like when i
take a gig i don't want i go
if i don't say yes they'll stop asking
the fear comes in
i should go just so people see me
and see the material i'm doing another
fear-driven thing so that they go oh
whitney's been doing that already or
whatever
um
or
like i just need to let people know i'm
still
like hitting the smaller shows like i
don't think i'm better than anyone i'll
still do small shows you know what i'm
saying yeah all of that it's all fear
driven and it's all trying to control
people's perception right yeah it's all
for me it's like i'm still very much in
a building phase for my career and i am
like if you say no to this
you are literally missing an opportunity
to build your career and now is the time
to be doing that and i
i do think that's true for me
um
but i don't always know what's the right
move what's the right thing to say yes
to
and
do you have why would i yeah but i but i
not asking for help is kind of my thing
how's that going
but why is it helped that's the other
thing i mean it's not even it's just
acting like i don't know there's nothing
elenants want more than you to ask them
for help yeah i know i'm like i am the
most uh i'll pretend like i know i would
rather pretend like i know what i'm
doing yeah yeah than to admit like hey i
don't know this sure i'd rather and it's
so fucking obnoxious it literally it
delays my own growth
so much
and you know what else is wild like i
when someone say asks
like how do you do this or someone that
i work with or someone on any staff no
matter what the
whether it's ep or writer's assistant or
pa production assistant when someone's
like hey i'm not sure how to do this
when someone asks a dumb question like
that yeah it makes me trust them so much
more yeah because i'm like oh if you had
the sort of like lack of shame because
you really just want to get the job you
want to do the job right you don't want
me to like you you're not worried about
that you're trying to get the job right
and if you have the sort of um ability
to ask me that right it means i can
trust you yeah when it's a big thing
you're going to really ask yeah i've
been learning really uh how to do that
in uh
in the writer's room for che's show
cause obviously i'm i'm the only white
writer in there and i don't know what
the fuck everybody's talking about like
a lot of the time yeah and i have to be
like hey uh real quick
let's ski sorry
i'm just like i don't know who this
person is or like what the
and rather than just be like googling
the whole time
yeah he saw weedy yeah just like they're
like i get to ask that and then
and then a lot of times a new sketch
idea will come out from you just being
authentic i think it's really just an
over-developed sense of responsibility
and it's not like
i cause whenever i ask or tell myself
just ask then i do it you know what i
mean i'm not like gripped with fear at
the idea of asking it's just an over
developed skill that i have to
do shit on my own without asking for
help and so my go-to is to do that thing
is to just do it on my own but
i'm getting better and better all the
time at just being like hey i need i
need i need a hand my
codependent hack for that is knowing how
much
people love to help
yeah i'm saying yeah so i'll ask because
i'm like okay you're gonna get so much
out of being like i just helped her yeah
yeah like i know you're gonna get so
much out of it yeah that i'm gonna give
you this gift and that's why like
especially the narcissist in my life i'm
like how do you do this and they're like
here i am to save the day like i know
i'm making their day by needing
something from them yes being needy is
underrated i'm so into it it makes other
people feel
important you're giving someone a gift
when you ask them to do something or i
don't know i just made a list of people
that i know
just being like oh that person's gonna
love when i ask them for help with this
like seriously i i think that's such a
great
skill yeah to uh and even if i know the
answer it's also just worth asking
people or i'm like i think i know this
answer but like i just want to hear this
person's line of thinking you know and i
think that that comes from being in
program where you just go like i think i
have a good idea but i also thought it
was a good idea uh at two in the morning
to climb my ex-boyfriend's parents house
yeah uh when i was 22 and like build a
rope and like because i thought he was
cheating like i also thought that was a
good idea so maybe let me just
make sure
i always assume my ideas are wrong i
always just assume i'm wrong yeah
i um i don't know if i do or i think i
most of the time
assume that i'm right
which by the way but after this long and
recovery you might just be do you know
what i'm saying like
a lot of the time i feel like i am
and
i've spent more time convincing myself
that i uh
that i'm right then i think that i'm
wrong now
uh you trust your instincts yeah i do
um uh this is another thing i heard that
kept me going back is someone said
alcoholics are the only people who
believe they deserve to be having fun
all the time oh god yeah and i was like
who wouldn't
like but like it was like news to me the
idea that like oh yeah life entails
uncomfortable moments for everybody and
like you don't deserve to be the one
person that never feels uncomfortable
right yeah and they're like but i was
uncomfortable my whole life like i
deserve to not be uncomfortable ever
again like i thought there was some kind
of like score system of like i paid my
dues on that front right so now everyone
needs to walk on eggshells around my
wounds right
well
we now very smoothly transition out of a
probably
lovely conversation uh with rosebud
baker uh rosebud baker myself probably
being angry at something that's frankly
just fine
uh but
we want to just let you know really
quick that the touch me tour has added
cities
benton
cities denver denver milwaukee atlanta
springs
minneapolis what sounds better
that's not the point that's not the
point okay language changes all the time
keep going uh cleveland chicago columbus
seattle boise idaho uh san diego salt
lake city nashville durham charlotte
north carolina charleston
bloomington wilmington delaware
cincinnati bethlehem pennsylvania
montclair new jersey omaha kansas city
uh toronto you need a good passport
bench toronto canada grand rapids
oh can i say richmond virginia yes
richmond virginia richmond virginia
grand rapids portland oregon new
hampshire charlottesville virginia
austin texas albany san fran
philadelphia vancouver british columbia
have you ever been to british columbia
benton no
i've been to florida
we're gonna be in tyson's quarter
virginia my old stomping ground my mom
used to work at the tysons corner
bloomingdale's oh can we go there uh
maybe i used to shoplift there a lot so
and we'll do it again
i would like we need to come back and
apologize and reimburse you for all that
ck1 that i stole in 1997 how about that
so now that i'm in a total fear panic
about uh adding all of these cities and
that
basically knowing that all of
this touring is gonna wreak havoc
um on my relationship it's time for me
to spend some quality time with our
showrunner and my best friend that i do
not pay
to be my best friend at all her name's
emily noonan i want to discuss what's
going on with her she's been using
better help and frankly i'm a little
jealous because all of her problems are
getting solved she's getting great
licensed therapy she's happy and it's
frankly pissing me off
i used to be who you went to for your
problems so let's just let's just let's
re let's get back in let's dig into it
let's see if i can give you better
advice than your better health counselor
come on let's let's bond okay let's get
back i feel like your better health
counselor has drawn a
driven a wedge between us she probably
drew it too yeah she's like take all the
toxic people out of your life
yeah yeah look in the mirror lady
she told me that
uh all right well here's go let's see
well here's what i haven't talked to her
about okay how do i stand up for myself
oh my god you want to stand up again
please don't
okay so not qualified for that problem
noted uh how about okay well i've been
feeling really down lately any advice
there yes i do i have some advice your
better health counselor will not give
you great okay
ayahuasca
have you heard of the ayahuasca the
plant medicine
no you go to peru
and you drink a poisonous plant
if that doesn't suit your fancy micro
dosing mushrooms ketamine is even
available now
and the whole deal with it is that it is
incredibly dangerous to do
but if you do it and don't die
that's when you start to really live
emily
but if i do die
i die problem solved
maybe you should be a better health
counselor yeah okay all right maybe that
was too risky that was too big of a
swing right
hear me out okay shopping shopping
addictions get a bad rap i think online
shopping putting yourself in debt
actually can really wake you up a little
bit right because the key to happiness i
think is to buy a bunch of stuff you
can't afford
then you realize money can't buy you
happiness so then you get happy
you know what i'm saying like what if
you wouldn't bought something super
expensive went downtown and then got it
stolen then you'll realize money doesn't
buy you happiness that's zen i bet your
better health counselor would never
have the audacity to tell you that life
hack no no no because she's a licensed
professional
uh if any of the advice you're getting
sounds like this you should try better
help instead they'll match you to your
own counselor who won't put you in
dangerous situations and you can start
communicating with them in under 48
hours 48 hours
what a coincidence that's how long my
last soul-searching acid trip lasted you
should try acid emily
or acid or
i can stay signed up with better help
and you can sign up for better help and
meet with a professional counselor from
the comfort of your own home anywhere in
the world in fact so many people are
using better health that they're
recruiting new counselors in all 50
states you should not apply
try it today this podcast is sponsored
by betterhelp and good for you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com whitney that's
betterhelp.com
w-h-i-t-n-e-y fine emily go to a
licensed professional therapist fine go
get better
godspeed
as a comic i like to focus more on like
darker shit interesting because
to me
everything that's sad is funny to me i
mean sad things always make me laugh i
don't know why the only thing that makes
me laugh yeah it just it just cracks me
up to whenever i hear like bad news or
like
i remember i was like i don't even know
what bad news you're talking about and
i'm already like i'm like my mom called
me and she was like charlie not charlie
astros dead and i started laughing and
it's like my dog
but it was just such a weird way to
start a phone call yeah yeah yeah yeah
then i was i was like well i guess i can
hang up you know but like you just so
when people are you warm me up for that
you just do the funniest things yeah
like there's no
cool way to do that
yeah and i think that um
comedy's about like the unexpected
happening yeah and so is tragedy so why
wouldn't they go hand in hand sure oh
yeah the dog died it's a surprise good
news bad news that someone jumped out of
a cake you know regardless of what it is
yeah but so is that um do you talk much
about your
somebody jumping out of a cake with a
saw
good news bad news
um good news is jumped out of a cake bad
news killed everyone at the party do you
okay i'm only gonna talk about this one
time yeah uh because i'm just fascinated
by after watching your special there's
your mind is so unique thank you in a
way that i wouldn't want to hang out in
there for too long
uh but i also would because the people
that i think ostensibly are like able to
be the quote unquote darkest or that
like talk about to me are the ones that
move through life with light because
they've purged it you know you're living
in the light if you're living with grace
because you don't have your shadow self
hiding in there your shadow self is kind
of what you present to the world and i
was like this is so exciting to me
because this this i think a lot of
people go like oh this person's so
fucked up all they do talk about dark
stuff it's like no no the healthiest
people are able to say all that and they
don't have to go home and yeah hide
their dark shit yeah you know and do
things in the shadows yeah people who
have kink in their lives aren't out
there raping too much i mean probably
they are yeah but you know i i just i
try to i tried a comparison and it fell
what do you want
i mean
i think the second
i look first of all who did this poll
now that i'm saying it um there's a it
was something that was like the women's
fantasies sexually are
uh rape is number
one
or two it goes back and forth but it's
always either one or two yeah i think
we're actually mistaking
uh a fantasy for exposure therapy
but also whose poll was this right do
you know what i'm saying yeah
i feel like this is no one asked me like
whenever there's a poll i'm like i i
need to know someone that was in this
study to have any kind of legitimacy
with like who right i want to interview
the guy who was like let's figure this
out excuse me ma'am what's your favorite
way to get fucked rape like no woman
because you know why you wrote it it had
to be an option in the study it wasn't
women were just like rape like it was
like no woman would think to say even if
it was there had to be like here's some
options picked from those right yeah
nobody's gonna go into a scientist maybe
they were just calling rape maybe they
were just calling for help yeah maybe
that because
like what's your favorite way to come
what's your kinky like ew i don't like
this study
even though i reference it all the time
as if it's legitimate
well that's you just you just hear it
and you go i can't let that go because
what the fuck yeah but like we're like i
am so when david sinclair was here who
was like a
the like an award-winning the biggest
genetics professor like scientist person
and he was talking about the study with
rats and he's like oh well rats you know
they run faster when they're given this
certain pill
and my brain this to me is a normal
thought and a good idea
i was like well how do you know they
weren't just running faster that time
because you were like hovering over them
looking at them right what if they were
just scared of you yeah and he was like
literally no one has asked that like
he's like no one no one like i just i
can't let anything be legitimate i'm
like yeah but there's uh here's why that
happened yeah yeah i think that's um i
think every comic has
like questioned everything yeah i think
there's like a thing that and
and i don't think it's just a comic
thing i think it's a lot of people but
um a couple of us have chosen to do
comedy really um i always say that
because i feel like people listening
comics are always going like only comics
do this and i feel like people
listening are like no that's not true
i also do that i mean i'm listening
because i relate but um
so
yeah yeah only comics uh feel this way
which is why millions of non-comics
listen listen to this thing
but i think that's narcissism the
there's like an analytical part for you
what i admire in your comedy is you
you're able to
analyze and pick things specific things
apart that i wouldn't think to pick
apart you know like i
and i see why that's
your both your like your gift and also
the maybe a thing that could fuck you up
sometimes yeah
but
i
i think it is your your gift like that's
you've made that work for you
comedically you know yeah i mean i think
for me it's like i always was as a kid i
was always frustrated by things no one
else cared about like i would like drive
me nuts yeah that a tank top was called
a wife beater and i couldn't like how is
everyone just going through life like
with this like i couldn't right like i
would just get so indignant about things
that were seemingly mundane and it made
me feel crazy to observe something that
no one else noticed yeah and it made me
feel like um you know terminally unique
uh
but uh so which doesn't end well later
but
yeah i think for me i just get so
obsessed with certain things and
you know i think
everyone can relate to getting obsessed
with something that no one else kind of
cares so even if you don't see what i
see or care as much it's funny that i
care so much about it right so i'm
saying someone's like even if i don't
relate you have a desire to understand
it's so funny that she's lost sleep over
this dumb thing right
but it needs to make sense to you like
it needs to you have to have it make
sense when i found out
there was such a thing as a blood bank
i didn't sleep when i learned there was
a building full of bags of blood right
i
would go up to strangers like do you
know about blood banks do you know that
they're just buildings full of blood and
like did you know that like i can't when
i found out that that's
like think it through think about this
building it's full of blood yeah what if
it collapses what if there's an
earthquake like where is it yeah is
there a generator like people's blood
like i just was like
there's blood in the streets we all we
need to we needed to have a symposium
about the blood like this is not a
tenable invention like i just didn't
like kidnap and then when i found out
that there are so a friend of mine uh uh
dana uh who i met in chicago at zany's
when i the first time i ever headlined a
club uh was in zany's this was like 15
years ago and she came up to me to sushi
restaurant
she recognized me from like chelsea
lately or something i was like she was
like i love you and i was like i was the
first time i was ever recognized yeah by
somebody yeah and i didn't know that you
just go like thank you i was like
here's my number let's hang out yep it
was the first part and she was like
what and we're friends now i can't tell
you how many times
i've been well yes i can because it's
happened three times but
i've been in an airport somebody's come
up and been like your rosebud and i've
been like yeah you want to take a
picture and they've been like no
and i'm like oh okay
can i take you to dinner
my thing is like oh but we're friends
now like this is how we met yeah this is
our mute but which is not sustainable
but i'm so glad i got to maybe she
wanted to be your friend i'm not sure
it's not i think she's friends now right
yeah but i think it was sort of like i
was used to being all of you but now
that you inspired me but now that you
want to hang out with me now i've lost
respect for you i mean that's what it is
like you were my role model but now you
just talk to any random person in a
sushi restaurant let them be your friend
like you must not have that much going
on
your boundaries aren't that strong i
think that people find me really um
and i don't know about this and i try
not to think about it too much but i i
don't think people find me like
approachable and i'm trying to like get
better about it about it i don't know
what it is i think maybe it's just the
fact that i've literally never smiled
like in where i'm just sitting there
smiling sure but people
see me and they go she's like not
reachable or something like i'm not
emotionally reachable i think that's a
good thing um i am i used to be so what
i just call like porous like my energy
would just um dove david off i'm sure
you know uh comedian in new york one
time uh we were outside i think this
must have been 15 years ago we're
outside the communist patio
and he was like why does everyone think
they're such good friends with you like
your energy is so
um like contagiously neat like something
like i do i i did it took me a long time
to work on like walling myself off a
little bit more in terms of like you
know you just vibrate at a different
frequency when you're not self-contained
and when you're not constantly obsessing
over everybody else's opinion about you
right when you're present it's very um
off-putting to people or it's just like
it doesn't have to be like oh she's a
bitch it's like oh she's just doesn't
she's not inviting me in with her energy
right i used to be such a like whore
with my energy even accidentally i
didn't know it and i was like i don't
know what you're talking about she was
he's like i'm telling you the craziest
people here walk up to you every time
i'm talking to you they come up and
they're just hey we need to talk to you
about something or like can i get a ride
home and they ask you things that are so
inappropriate and you give it to them
like you attract this right and i was
like i don't know what you're talking
about in that moment a man
with a doll house on his head
where his he did stand up as a doll
house and his eyes were the windows and
he was like hey whitney i need to talk
to you about something and i literally
was like i guess you are right i am a
magnet for
crazies i'm a magnet and for people to
run around and go like i'm a magnet for
crazy crazy people love me like what's
going on with you you're inviting that
in like because when he walks by i'm
like cool yeah i'm like trying to i love
your dollhouse
like i'm doing something that's making
giving them the green light yeah whether
it's eye contact whether it's body
language which is part of the reason i
work with horses because it's all body
language right because you can say
something or mean something and not say
it the way you mean it and communication
is 70 body language so you can try to be
like i don't want to talk to that person
but if you're if you're just
subconsciously letting them know that
your space is available to them like to
me
that just means you're self-contained
and have good boundaries and you're not
actively moving through the world
future fucking or going like what is
this person like you're just giving off
the vibe right you're at the airport in
the present moment because you are
well i'm just going to accept that
because that uh that fully just makes me
feel better good you know i have to put
on headphones i have to put on like a
hat even when i like wrap my head and
sharp people excuse me are you whitney
i'm like why are you touching me
is it what is it about me yeah that
makes people think i think there is uh
part of it is charisma and warmth and
you have both of those things and i
don't have warmth i think i have
charisma i don't think i have warmth i
watch people watch me but then they
don't
want to approach me you know what's
weird if you dyed your hair black people
would think you had worms i'm not even
joking what so when i swear to god so
when i had black hair everyone thought i
was so nice they're like she's so nice
you're so nice i had no idea you were
this and then when i dried my hair
blonde those couple years ago everyone
thought i was a bitch oh so you're
saying give them the opposite so i dress
like i fucking graveyards here's what
happens
and then people see and they go she's
actually really nice i want people to
feel comfortable around me in a way that
they just don't right right just don't
but that's you know okay but also
you know this is can i say something
wild what's your in the birth order you
are out of five i'm the oldest the
oldest interesting
the hero that's the oldest hero yeah
well the oldest gets the most weirdly
the most attention because but they get
the worst kind of attention they get
smothered and they get it's when uh
parents have a kid they don't they've
never had a kid before yeah so every
time you cough it's like they're dead
they're like they get the most manic
energy right and then by the second or
third kid parents like oh no it's fine
we know what that is oh see i
i don't know that that was how what
happened amazing
at least in my family my mom was
pregnant my entire uh for the first 10
years of my life so she wasn't able
always pregnant
and so
i i felt like
growing up and even now like when
something big happens in my life like it
doesn't no one
i'll like let my family know but like i
don't i don't really involve them
because i kind of just figured things
out like myself you're like you
basically had to take care of yourself
very young so you're probably precocious
and very like self-contained yeah yeah
and able to i'm like i got it i figured
it that's so interesting yeah it's like
being the oldest for sure you had to
because you don't have older siblings
but did you have to care for your
younger siblings
was that like uh uh that was really more
i mean honestly the sister that was born
after me
she's a nurse
and she is
much more like the oldest of the family
than i am like
she bought her house first she's having
a baby she's like doing like she's
really even though i'm older than her
she's much more like the older sibling
interesting and like when i would run
away from home she would get yelled at
okay this is fascinating it is so
um
unusual to talk to someone that has the
kind of uh
wiring that you have and has done the
kind of work that you've done the kind
of self-awareness that you have and it's
making me so excited um i want to talk
to you about red flags in people and in
relationships etc like you are someone
that clearly yeah okay so for me a major
red flag is always when somebody
i haven't talked to somebody in a few
weeks and they text are you mad at me
um that that's a huge red flag for me i
immediately because
because why would i be thinking about
you go there
yeah why would you go there and also
like why would i be also what did you do
i don't even think like that i know but
there is something about like what did
you do
what did you do were you just being like
where the fuck is is whitney why the
fuck is sinji texting me back hey are
you mad at me yeah like do you have some
kills yeah for me there's always one
friend in my life that's mad at me that
i'm unaware of uh that i like is just
like i'm not giving them enough
attention or i'm not like doing enough
in their shit in their life
and um i
i'm just unaware of it i just have no
idea there's probably like six people
that are mad at me right now that i
don't know of um sure and i'm always
getting told like
you're always like doing your own thing
and my husband even will be like i don't
um
i don't like
i feel like you
other things are a priority you know and
i'm not it's that's not the case like i
i'm always like thinking about him but
i'm just not like texting him that i'm
thinking can i ask you if you guys done
your love language thing
no i haven't done any other shit with
him okay i might do it with you before
we leave because it is fascinating to me
to be in a relationship where i finally
believe that i'm like say what i mean
mean what i say don't say a mean i'm
only doing 50 percent i'm not obsessing
over the other person i'm not trying to
control them
but then when they don't receive my love
in the way that it's intended where it's
like well you didn't say thank you for
this thing it's like
but i fucking left a show early to come
hang out with you you know to me it's
acts of service and like the things that
i give up for you which i can't say but
you need to just hear thank you yeah i'm
like why do you it's obvious that i'm
grateful yeah like my brain just goes
like why aren't you looking these other
nine big actions i took instead of these
two words i said because words are like
meaningless to me yeah but not to
everybody yeah i think words for me are
are really important like if if the
conversations that i'm having with you
are draining me i'll i'll just uh
i i start to pull away very quickly sure
you know so you have a very conscious
understanding of if like someone's an
energy vampire like it's repellent to
you yeah very much so like and and if
someone is um
like forced intimacy for me is always
like a red flag
um i try to let all the relationship
relationships in my life develop
organically where like there's a real
understanding between me and the person
and we
we have things to talk about uh that
leave us both feeling like alive and
happy
um basically like meritocracy
friendships it's not just like let's be
besties and then you're like oh yeah
nothing in common we trauma bonded or i
was lonely or i need whatever yeah or i
had some kind of
you know um this person
essentially had the negative qualities
of my primary caretaker so i was like
tricked into believing that we were like
soul mates or whatever like new old
friends yeah i'm like he's depressed and
he walks 10 feet ahead of me in public
i'm in love he's got seven bumper
sticker on the car he drives that
belongs to his girlfriend
um but i'm a that is such a good one are
you mad at me here's another one hey
stranger
hey stranger hey stranger so if you have
a friend that you haven't seen in a
couple weeks because you're and they're
like hey stranger which is like a
passive aggressive way of saying like
where have you been why aren't right why
are we you know instead of just like hey
i miss you let's hang out yeah anybody
that activates like any sort of we're
trying to use guilt to manipulate or
yeah that's the intention
that's the intention behind it and it's
like
i don't like i don't owe you anything
nothing um
so that i'm like i'm not your mom
i don't i'm not your dad i can't i can't
help you sure
and by the way it's also like you know
that and um
you know better yeah i'm saying or
you're like your inner child's writing
the show whatever it is but those are
tricky ones because um sometimes though
somebody's just saying hey stranger you
know like sometimes i'm like maybe i
maybe there's like this risk where
i actually just feel guilty already
and they say hey stranger and i go what
the fuck does that mean yeah right okay
so my guilt that you already existed
before you texted me it's not gonna come
um i wrote a couple down too just as you
think of other ones because i'm really
curious yeah in your red flags because
to me i always want to talk about not
like how to solve this problem or get
out of this mess how to avoid being in
the mess in the first place that's what
sobriety emotional sobriety is right you
know yeah so to me instead of like
here's how to get out of a bad
relationship here's how to avoid the bad
relationship in the first place because
we're dying you're running out of time
pull it together
where's jewelry from a college sports
team
oh yeah someone that's like really into
their college is their identity and
their everything it's like if you showed
up in if i don't care if you work at
fucking um
like if you work on wall street and you
show up in your company's merch
i'm gonna be like you're a loser
you know is that your goldman sachs
hoodie you got the retreat like we get
it yeah like i i sometimes feel that way
even just walking around in like like
like a comic comedy story like any sort
of merch i'm just like god i'm a loser
one time i okay so jimmy kimmel
the hoodies that he used to give in the
gift bags no joke are these softest
hoodies they're like re-washed we should
see who makes them vented because they
were so soft and they fell right below
your hip a lot of hoodies now are like
belly hoodies that come up really high
and i'm like i have a long torso knives
so i love the same very long torso
really can't touch my hands to the
ground when i'm sitting straight up
can't do it like i am a i'm like a t-rex
short arms long torso makes for a huge
forehead
so who told you all this i just
discovered it i just looked at myself
and was like what dinosaur would i be
i think you're like a pixie dream girl
you're a total pixie dreamer this is
like i mean this is a it's every man's
dream you're a helena and boxing helena
no arms no legs just no i'm helena
helena bonham carter in fight club is
closer to the
yeah and that um yeah going to a bunch
of meetings because we're addicted to
meetings
i wish that was my addiction people when
i'm like yeah i have the talent i'm
meeting then i have an aca meeting and i
go to a code meeting like oh my god do
you like that girl who's addicted to
going to meetings i'm like no i'm just
sick yeah yeah no i don't have the
problem i'm just very ill no i have to
go to all these it's the glue that's
holding me together okay
and you have to be like no
yeah you know what else is a weird
little red flag when you you know i'm so
people have talked about this at nauseam
but when women you know just inherently
apologize for our existence all the time
and how we just go like sorry sorry
sorry when we're not you're not sorry
you're just kind of codependent or in
fear or whatever yeah and it's kind of
just like a tick you know sorry sorry
right when someone accepts the apology
oh god someone said oh no you're good
i'm like oh i will kill you no i didn't
do no i that was a no if i say sorry
accidentally and you say it's okay i'm
gonna punch you in the face
i just did that because i've been
programmed to be smaller as a woman and
i'm just trying to make other women like
me so that's kind of why i say i'm sorry
all the time but you can't yeah i take
it back
that's when i really cut the habit out
when someone's oh you're good and i was
like no i know yeah i
was so funny to be like i take it back
yeah no that wasn't that was like a tick
that was an old thing i do that was an
old habit that i do yeah yeah
oh god i feel like a radio dj did that
to me no i know it was like like moose
and wait but do you think saying sorry
is the red flag is that what you're
saying no it's when when somebody says
it's okay when someone accepts an
apology that's not real absolutely i
need to work on giving the apology
that's not real yeah to be fair but also
you know i'm not really you know what
this is yeah and also you're not a king
you know i'm just a shell of a person
you know what's happening here yeah
don't make this worse by implying i did
something wrong yeah no it's what
whatever that's definitely right you
just agreed that i should be sorry for
my existence yeah so now we have a
problem yeah that's a bad one that is a
bad one to me that's someone that just
can't read a room i think and i get very
i feel very nice if someone can't just
read a room
it implies that they
believe you should be sorry right that
you are or even worse they just weren't
listening wait is that worse
to me the most annihilating thing that
can happen if someone doesn't listen to
what i'm saying when i talk so if i go
like sorry if you were listening you
would know i was like just in a tick you
know
i would rather someone not listen to me
than um have them believe that i should
be sorry for
my existence
personally like i just remember like
when that happened to me that's just
someone that's not like conscious and i
just like people that are really
oriented and super conscious devil in
the detail people yeah and that confront
something head-on
uh even if it's uncomfortable so to me i
think it's kind of more about more about
that yeah also
adding to the list uh people that say
yes to everything when they agree with
everything yeah calls his ex crazy big
one or her or friends that call
their friends they're currently friends
with crap gossiping about your current
friends is a big one
and
a guy or girl who's all their exes are
crazy and they're the common denominator
and all the crazy so what's going on
with you that you were right with all
those people that are crazy or why did
you stay so long if they're so crazy you
had no part in it at all yeah zero
people that only blame right only blame
because you're next yeah people that
only blame
is i think the best way to put that
because
my
my head went because
there's friends that i'm i'm still very
good friends with that i go they are a
little crazy but i'm never saying it
like they're crazy but you know what it
is you know that it's either a
limitation you know that it's an ism you
know that it's low self-esteem like you
know i don't know exactly why
that fits with my neuroses you know it's
like you know there's a difference
between being tolerant of people that
are sick and suffering or don't have the
tools yeah and someone that's just crazy
i don't even know if i'd call anyone
crazy like when i think crazy i think of
someone that like is a sadistic or like
gets off on like
big pranks or like the kind of person
like pushes someone in a pool to party
it's like the phone their phone's in
their pocket oh my god that literally
happened to me two weeks ago i was out
of wedding crazy that's crazy to me
like yeah to me pushing you in the pool
hilarious but i first go where's your
phone yeah is your phone there and then
i would do it but someone just pushed us
out that's crazy i remember falling in
the pool and
just
this is also equally as crazy felt
falling in the pool all my clothes on
first thing that came up out of the
water was my phone just
just coming out like one hand
like dawn of the dead like larry elway
the princess bride coming out of the
sand yes i was like this is equally as
fucking insane but i was i hadn't i
think i swam all the way like a shark
just my hands above the water like
swimming to the side funny like you have
small arms
very short arms long torso
but also it's like it is so funny
because it's like god forbid this
addiction i'm trying to get sober from
like the thing that i'm asking for is i
just want two days no phone i feel like
i could i could get emotionally sober on
the phone and then i have an opportunity
for that and i'm like i can't yeah no i
can't i've never even tried i've never
tried to get this is how i know i have
an addiction is that um to the phone is
that if somebody goes are you addicted
to that i'd be like no
protest too much
you know if you're not you can go like
you know what i might be yeah you know
what i mean like you can entertain the
idea so it's like it's the the level of
defensiveness within you is always such
a
great way to see red flags with other
people too oh do you feel like you drink
too much no i don't change it much right
but someone who's like yeah you know
what i might it's possible right if you
can entertain the two things can be true
at once or that you can be wrong or have
made a mistake absolutely that's like
that's a good time that's when you can
fuck with somebody right but someone
who's like all or nothing black or black
or white thinking is a big red flag
somebody's like all people do this and
oh so basically don't take comedians
yeah you know what i'm saying i was
going to say it doesn't slightly drink
tequila it's like okay well something's
going on here that's right it has to be
so abstemious and controlled that's
either a control addiction or something
else is going on yeah i i think that i
run into a lot of um
my brain gets caught
between like
how does that fit into my this is just
the case with mental health in general
where like i'll be seeking mental health
but then i'm like how is that going to
be funny like i'll i'll be like how is
that going to help me as a comic and
and
because i really focused a lot on myself
during the pandemic but i would be
sitting there going
i'm sorry it's covered um fine hang on
please
i'd love to get covered um god yeah i'll
take a look i can get yeah um
so i would be focusing on myself but
then i'd be like what is so funny about
me like
you know just calling a friend and
really connecting and uh seeing somebody
smile on the street and i just felt good
for the rest of the day i'm like what is
funny about that i love that you think
mental health is seeing someone smile
and then being happy that is from that
person no i mean for me if i'm like if
somebody smiles at me on the street and
i'm just like god it's a great life you
know yeah
okay i see what you mean just having a
well i think there's i'm just peaceful
and feeling good and then i'm like who
how
how if i meet that person i'm like how
is this funny or i don't have any uh
sort of um
uh rage or any kind of like anger which
is i think i love in your special the
way you talk about is really poignant
and hilarious and so
just helpful um i think there is a war
on anger i think it is such an
underrated emotion i think it's so
powerful and important if you're
harassing it properly and we're so wired
to like don't ever be angry it's like no
what i mean anger's always sadness
especially for women it's like if you're
if you're an angry woman you're a
fucking bitch
i'm like i am so angry all the time
and
it is one of the only emotions that i
don't feel shame about so i i try to
like
i'm just trying to like advocate for it
because it's like
it's a fucking great feeling it's a
great feeling because adrenaline turns
into dopamine so when you are angry that
does feel good it is self-soothing but
it's also i mean based on what we come
from people have different
levels of it you know but i think that
anger is is an incredibly healthy
emotion because it's never unfair it's
never there when it's not warranted in
some way you know what i mean like it's
a pretty um meritocracy in terms of who
has it like if someone you're like oh
this white guy's being angry like how
would you have to be complete
he was molested something something
happened to this person right you know
what i'm saying so it's like when you
see angry people there's something i
actually trust or have compassion for
angry people before i do uh docile
people because i'm like oh you're just
sad something bad happened to you yeah
like i know what to do with you right i
know to just forgive you right i know to
just feel bad yeah yeah
yeah i'm not gonna take your anger
personally because something awful
happened to you right you know like
you're suffering and this is your drug
rage yeah and um but the point i'm
trying to make oh i know what you mean
about that but i do feel like we should
give ourselves permission to be
whatever kind of mental stability we
have i do not think it is gonna hurt us
as
funny people and artists i think it's
only gonna addre because you're never
gonna stop being funny you can't not
right you already the bar is already set
you already have too many comedians
around you who are going to like keep
you honest that you're gonna want to
impress and be funny for like that's
never gonna go away and you'll always
have adversity and comedy because we're
monsters right um
but i think what it will do because i
did that for a long time i'm like i
can't be in a healthy relationship i
can't be healthy or else i won't be
funny anymore what it does is it really
just makes it so you say no to those
things that you need to say no to and
then you stay just as funny right i'm
saying or you see those family members
you want to see that you've been
avoiding and then you're still just as
funny yeah it's also like one of those
thoughts that you have that you go
uh this thought's not going to help you
you know what i mean where you're like
hey if you're mentally healthy
um you're gonna stop being funny i'm
like i have so many thoughts like that
where i go all right thanks
but you know like it's not whatever like
true yeah it's not true and it's also
like
if it
even if it were true if it's something
that i was gonna grab onto and obsess
about
and to keep myself in one particular
place i i'm just like nah yeah you know
yeah i think it's like you know look
what we do is already so inherently
mentally destabilizing and and you know
the the feelings of reward are ephemeral
and mercurial you know you can kill one
night the next night one weirdo at a
show who's drunk can ruin your whole
night you know what i mean even though
the show was fine like we have there's
so many ways to hurt ourselves and
there's so many ways to get hurt and
what we do already that it took me a
long time to realize like oh no if i
have every other hour of my day mentally
healthy and stable and safe and
consistent and serene borderline boring
yeah i still am gonna get
the drama and the chaos and the hurt
feelings and the toxic shit i'll get it
yeah what i'm saying yeah like i don't
have to and in fact your tolerance will
just get lower so then
those
fewer moments of toxicity will hit
harder yeah means i do you know what i
mean yes yeah i mean the only reason i'm
not saying anything is because i am
fully in agreement with that um
thank you that was really hard to uh say
for some reason you know what else is a
red flag for me
bad at packing
bad in what way have you ever seen
someone just like fold stuff up in a
luggage and just like there's spaces on
the sides
yes it's so funny because
like is this really your ba you played
tetris as a kid you know this is not
it is so funny that you say that because
it was driving me fucking crazy on my
way over here i my husband does this
thing where um
he will
he'll he'll notice something's broken in
the house right like my suitcase was
broken and literally i had wrapped it up
in duct tape you're that person and he
was like i'm gonna return this and we're
gonna get a new one but he doesn't get
the new one in time so then i had to go
to my sister's place borrow a suitcase
from her it's way too big i look like
i'm if i took my suitcase out of the car
in here you would be like get out
because it looks like i'm moving in and
i was here for four days but i filled
the suitcase with shoe boxes so that
everything would stay
folded that is
fantastic
whose shoes who are the boxes they're
just i just brought like six pairs of
sneakers and then got it and then packed
them and put the boxes in there and then
put the boxes in the vacant spaces
because whatever i didn't have in
clothing or makeup
i just filled with sneakers sure and um
and by the way
packing makeup as a woman i i feel like
i am a makeup artist every time i go
somewhere
like i haven't i need another suitcase
for the makeup yeah that's the whole
thing it's a it's in a fridge yeah it's
infuriating how much shit we have to
bring places and then you go and they're
like
nobody ever thinks to be like
there's a makeup artist there there's
hair and makeup there and you show up
and you're just like
i have taken so many fucking makeup
classes
for myself i don't want to know how to
do my own makeup i literally i waited
until i was 34 to like take a makeup
class and it was
i had no idea what i was doing you look
great did you do your makeup i did do my
own makeup today i'm starting to be and
maybe this is just like getting older or
maybe this is just surrendering or like
being obsequious to whatever the man i
am so pro
how much harder quote unquote it is to
be a woman at this point i'm so into it
i've just leaned in the opposite way i'm
like yes i have an entire thing of
luggage for makeup yeah a lot of people
like you shouldn't have to do that
you're a woman i'm like you know what i
love the idea that i can get two hours
of sleep and then put on purple eyeliner
and no one will know guys you can't do
that i love when they call a 22 year old
brave because she walked outside with no
makeup on i'm like go
follow yourself
like it's not i mean
brave
i didn't wear makeup when i was 22
because i didn't have to like it's like
do you only call it brave when it's nice
to look at i know when it's like yeah if
i walked outside with no makeup on they
wouldn't call it brave they would be
like yikes how about being a woman in
anywhere walking outside with or without
makeup is brave yeah truly yeah
especially at night yeah
by the way walking me out walking
outside with no makeup is not is is
truly not brave at all because no guy's
gonna rape me unless let me see
what you said about like i'm so pro uh
everything's harder for uh to be a woman
i totally know narrative i know why
you're saying that because
there is that pull in every one of us
where it's like
i want to resist that
i want to resist going this is because
i'm a woman because i think that
by going immediately to that
you
sometimes miss
an opportunity to see somewhere where
you can actually just get better as a
person right
um so it's important to go is this
really because of sexism yeah or do i
have an area that i need to like get
better at because it's also yeah to me
it's like i don't wear makeup because
i'm a woman i wear makeup because i'm an
adult that has decide like i could
choose to not the idea that it's like
i'm doing this because of the patriarchy
like is that why you're doing like okay
but
i mean alicia keys is a bad example
because
i wouldn't wear makeup either if i look
like alicia keys but i'm just saying
like there's a certain point where you
have to take responsibility for your own
decisions and own your own shit and
decide like like stop blaming some vague
thing that's like okay so which is it so
so i'm saying on instagram i'm just
obsessed with sort of the hypocrisy
within sort of feminism right now and
how everyone's got to do it the same way
and like
you know everything that uh that makes
me feel comfortable is like a betrayal
of femininity oh like you have all this
makeup and you're using all this stuff
it's like you know what i grew up with
makeup is like my toys my mom works in a
department store i loved like creams
that's all i had i didn't have barbies
in my little ponies and stuff that was
like those were my toys i would go to um
uh it was called cvs at the time and i
would get like face scrubs and that's
just what i played with like that's you
know that's like a virgo's toy just
cleaners
but and then it makes me feel
comfortable it makes me feel confident
like i can still work on all the things
that you know uh are going on in terms
of me not feeling like i'm enough or
pretty enough for the dysmorphia and all
that but like at the end of the day it's
not that much work yeah for me
are you um
also
the shame anytime you use feminism to
shame another woman yeah well is like
that's the thing that
really bugs me i'm like how
how committed are you
to feminism
if you're using
uh if you're using another woman's lack
of perceived lack of feminism
yeah to
uh to shame her i'm like that's just not
how you get somebody on your side even
if you think that even if what you're
seeing is correct
it's not if you're trying to
do something for feminism and convince
someone to come
into feminism yeah you don't use shame
to do it it's like it's not well it's
just
bullying yeah
you're using something that's like
ostensibly like a good cause and you're
using it to bully the people that the
cause is supposed to benefit right so
you're just a bully hypocrite and you're
hiding behind this um sort of uh
protection of i'm doing it for all women
like yeah
bullying this one woman saying you're
not the version of feminism you're
supposed to be based on what i think it
should be which is a whole
that's your own matriarch it shouldn't
be a matriarch either one person's
vision you know it drives me nuts
because i know so many people now that
are like
that are like younger that either ask
for advice or that i meet or something
and i'm like you don't have to run a
company if you don't want to yeah you
don't have like you can just be a
florist if you want you know what i'm
saying
the goal is you have the options and
then you get to do what you choose right
the lack of options is the problem but
if you choose to be a makeup artist if
you choose to be a model if you choose
to be like that that should be what
happened not you need to subscribe to my
version of what feminism is which is
just me
um
being a sexist guy acting like the guys
yeah yeah yeah i'm saying like if
someone wants to wear makeup someone
like i just that shit really drives me
insane because i just
you know i i'm in so much forgiveness of
the older generations of women that
still have that scarcity complex and
that's still like bully other women
under the guise of being like protecting
feminism or something for the most part
i'm not seeing a lot of whatever
quote-unquote whatever feminism means i
don't
it all is just getting really right i'm
yeah no yes that's exactly it there's
just a lot of uh there's a lot of
shaming going on there's a lot of like
you're not enough it's like how are you
gonna how are you gonna say to a woman
you're not enough
yeah and then also and then also say of
a feminist it's just like that those two
things in the same
sentence if you on a daily basis wake up
and you do whatever the fuck you want
the whole day
you're a good feminist if you made all
the like choices based on it being what
you wanted to do you didn't hurt anybody
like you like you know what i'm saying
yeah that word i don't even use that
word like i just think it's gotten such
it's become such a joke yeah yeah sorry
that's fucked up like i it just doesn't
it have meaning to me
i did you have you read this book oh
fuck fuck fuck what's the name of the
book a feminist manifesto paperback
jessica chapin yes i think that's the
one
crispin sorry jessica crispin yeah
outspoken credit jessica crispin
delivers a searing rejection of
contemporary feminism and embracing
manifesto for revolution i don't want to
read this fucking book i want to read
books that i want to read that aren't
about being a better woman can i stop
i'm good i'm good yeah i don't need to
read more books about how to be a woman
or how to be a good woman or a bad woman
i want to stop thinking about being a
woman in general yeah i think i i just
want to wake up in the morning and just
be just be myself just be a person i
don't need to research any more
i'm saying of how
to be a strong woman you know what i'm
saying like just a decent person i don't
need more women making money off of
insecure women that want to be better
feminists yeah
yeah because it's really just the more
books i read about this the more i'm
just saying i'm not enough right i mean
this for me was like when i read this it
was about
i was feeling the same kind of like
feelings of just
i i felt critical of feminism and then i
felt guilty for that sure and i was like
why do i what's going on here
why am i seeing so many hypocrisies on
this side and then and then when i bring
those up i'm i'm just accused of being
a bad woman or a bad feminist when i i
think internalized misogyny i'm just
like
it's just nuance that i'm that i'm
capable of you know i just um yeah i
just it's i think that there's this
thing that happens when you
when
people that don't like women or want to
be in charge or are malignant
narcissists or want to be authority
figures or get off or sadistic get off
on criticizing other people
like
using the feminism like people
a lot of people are just born and they
respect other women they don't have to
be told to do it they don't have they
were raised that way a lot of people are
you don't have to read 50 books to learn
how to respect women so it's like when
women are like well you need to read
this book it's like i like women i don't
i got it yeah you have maybe you had to
read this book because it's so foreign
to you to just
kind of treat
so there's a little bit of like everyone
needs to read this thing it's like
don't prescribe me based on what you
think the illnesses and other people
it's just they're basically just saying
get in line with my didactic version of
what how you need to act for me to feel
comfortable yes i don't want you wearing
makeup i don't mean being loud i don't
like being sexual don't make sex jokes
don't do this and this and this it's
just like oh wow you don't have any good
sex drugs yeah yeah my sex trips are
better than yours like what is like what
are we doing yeah i mean like it's just
like um but then again
i'm the first to say
you know in terms of like the like women
bullying other women stuff men bully men
too
yeah you know what i'm saying maybe it's
not a woman thing like everyone's like
women are so toxic to other women yet
men are toxic to other men and commonly
limited toxic
i'm like what the fuck it's like it's so
easy to
it's so i'm like i'm actually
very much for uh for bullying your
friends okay as long as they're your
friends it's fine i'm just like to me
feminism is like being able to go a day
without having to think about feminism
yeah here i'm saying like all day my did
i do this right am i is this do i need
to post this it's just like can i just
move through life without constantly
having to like grade myself of how
you know much i moved the ball down the
field today as a woman it's like also
it's implying you have so much power
that you can you know what i'm saying
yeah and i don't uh uh want to be you
know sort of dismissive or
self-deprecating but it's also just like
i don't when people like well you need
to do this because you have a platform
and you shouldn't be saying that like
thank you for thinking i have the power
to change everybody's childhood but like
i just there's just no way yeah but like
the fact that you're bullying means i
you want something i have or you're
jealous or something right that's how i
try to turn it because it's like
like
why do you think i need to be the person
that posts this thing or right i'll just
go you know what rosie you're not
you're not responsible for these people
like it's just just live your fucking
life yeah you know what i mean yeah
treat the people that know you very well
stay at it and treat other people as
well as you can yeah you know yeah stay
in your lane yeah i think that's what it
is for me you know but i would like to
get to a point as a female comic where i
don't always have to talk about being a
female com it's just it's like
it's just getting
very boring and it feels like this
unnecessary kind of pressure that's like
i mean listen it's just us two here and
we ended up talking about look at us so
it's so but it's you know but it's good
that we because we this book came up and
i and i definitely am like getting
unhinged about it because it's just i
guess for me when people it's like when
um
when the panel culture of like women
everyone needs to speak on panels about
how to be a successful woman how to be a
woman in business
and then some and i get these assets
like will you come speak at this event
about how to be a female entrepreneur
and i'm like great where is it they're
like it's noon at the hilton it's two
hours and i'm like how much does it pay
and they're like oh it doesn't pay and
i'm like so for me to come to that panel
i'm already not a good female
entrepreneur i'm leaving my actual job
that pays me at noon to come speak at
your panel for free
right i already shouldn't be listened to
oh yeah it's like how many um how much
are they paying the
the male ceos
yeah so it's like it's it's just to me
it's like the same thing with like i
i think the best way that i can be a
feminist whatever that means is to get
through my life without constantly only
talking i have other things going on in
my life without immediately going i'm a
female this yeah yes or just like any
kind of like yeah i don't know it just
it's just it seems like a weird uh way
to frame
your life i guess yeah um following porn
stars red flag
following them like following them on
instagram
um oh okay i thought you meant like
following them in general like following
them around definitely and i was like
yeah
yeah that goes on let's work on your
i would put that on there following them
uh on social media what happens when
your date you're dating a guy now you're
married to him were there any follow
conversations of who's this person
you're following
yeah i mean
yeah but i would just uh
i would just says or is it just it's
just most of the time i would i would
unfollow women on his phone
uh myself
i would just i'm just full disclosure i
would just look at his phone and be like
you don't need to see her anymore or her
like he was there when you did it yeah
no no
but i would but he would be like hey i
used to follow he basically would later
on be like oh yeah i used to follow this
girl but then rosie got on my phone and
uh deleted her from my from my contacts
or whatever and i'd be like yeah no i
did but it wasn't like uh i never felt
bad about going into my husband's phone
because i go into his phone so much that
i'll put his passcode into my phone
trying to log into my phone okay so
here's the deal once you are married is
it are your phones just
on limits yeah where is the privacy
within so can i just look through your
email at any time
him yeah yeah
yeah
he can just look through your text at
any moment he could dms on instagram he
could yeah i wouldn't i wouldn't be like
but also i'm not saying that everybody
should do that yeah you know i don't
think that like
it's like
it's really only if you think that you
are
because if you're going in there
wanting to find something bad
you'll find it but also like sometimes
i'll go in his phone wanting to find
something bad and then i'll i'll look at
it and go
well you wanted to find this you know
and then i don't really bring it up
because i'm like now you have to say
that you went through it not even i like
i just know that i
i'm like well you cut yourself it's like
it's like being upset that there's blood
after you cut yourself it's like well
that's part of the cleanup you know you
got to clean up your own blood so that's
sort of how
because it wasn't you weren't going into
it being like if i find something bad
i'm leaving you're like i just kind of
want to hurt myself right now i'll just
talk to my therapist about it instead of
talking to him yeah that's really smart
but it's also very it's way harder so
then i just go
if you're not allowed to talk to him
about it afterwards is it really worth
checking if you can only talk to your
therapist no you're just making a future
secret for yourself yeah yeah it's just
like a negative contribution to your
future self but how do you you know how
few people have the ability to have that
restraint
and to go i'm not gonna say this to you
i'm not gonna yeah go to the problem for
the solution i know this is my shit i'm
gonna like how do you have that pause is
that from doing work in um it's just
no it's like knowing that i uh
knowing before i do the thing that i'm
looking for something because i'll i'll
be like interesting as i'm doing it i
have this
i have this like
i'll say to myself like it's okay to do
something bad it's not okay to do
something that's bad for you
unconsciously so like if you're doing
something that's bad for you and you're
doing it consciously and meaning you
know exactly
why you're doing the thing
and what you're acting out
then it takes all of the joy out of the
scandalousness of it
so you kind of like are doing it but you
know that you're just
there's no high the easy you just get
low exactly i'm gonna go get low on it
it doesn't make you feel good so like
you know if he's following a porn star
on instagram and i
and let's say i'm not the kind of person
that would go into his phone and just
delete that porn star
which i am
but some days i'm not
um
i'll be like ah he's a guy he's
following a porn star
whatever yeah you know what the fuck
it's not gonna end our marriage it's not
gonna like yeah
she wants nothing to do with
most of the him
i'm like i love that in your little
brain that you think
that uh she would ever he's supporting a
sex worker yeah and you
took that away you you lowered a second
yeah yeah and um think about bad
feminists yeah i'm horrible
i'm terrible i don't support sex work i
just took her kid out of college and um
no i literally am just like
he's gonna be fine she doesn't want
anything to do with him if any if he
reaches out to her she's gonna think
he's sick
and it's
who gives a shit like i'm like she's
gonna think that you're like reaching
out with a spinal issue you have
you march your back a lot in your porn
yeah what do you use for your l5
fraction no he's going to be like hey
i'm dying can you come to my
you come to my hospital room
that's i'm just laughing because we were
probably hysterically laughing
now we take a smooth break that's not
jarring at all from those two gab and
geese to tell you a little bit about our
sponsors let's get into it
but why are you guys dressed like this
what are you wearing grace you don't
like my fur
uh i
i i fo faux fur
faux fur show
vote for show as long as i can put a
punch into it
i'm trying to do a pun grace it's called
comedy uh as i move forward in this
mentorship role with you
it's puns are the key to success great
so that's why i said faux fur show
because i also like faux fur not real
fur
you've seen my therapy bills you get it
okay but what you're wearing it's just a
lot it's you're wearing fur emily's
wearing a hat look what's happening here
emily you look like the ariah profile of
the childless sister of a real housewife
of orange county thank you
i don't understand why you're all
suddenly so overdressed for work oh we
just use earnest to help pay down our
student loans so now we can buy all the
things that we wanted to buy 10 years
ago but we're too in debt to afford and
right now ernest is offering our
listeners a hundred dollar cash bonus
refinance your student debt at
earnest.com whitney terms and conditions
apply ernest offers you low rate student
loan refinancing and you can check your
rate risk-free in just two minutes i
bought these accessories because i've
always wanted to know what it's like to
walk down the street and have people
think oh my god i hate her and if you've
ever wanted to know what that's like
ernest is giving our listeners a 100
bonus refinance your student loans at
earnest.com whitney terms and conditions
apply i know i always wanted to feel
that way that's why i bought this
engagement ring before earnest i had to
pretend to be engaged without a ring and
it was a lot more difficult people
thought it was crazy
and i just wanted attention 10 years ago
so i bought these titties
jesus
you look great benton yeah
benjen
yeah uh
i'm sorry i'm falling in love with you i
promised myself this would never happen
okay so you guys are like fake rich now
fake
i'm all cash baby call me liquid assets
earnest offers low rate student loans
refinancing so i got a radically
flexible payment plan to pick myself up
and you can do the same once again you
get a 100 cash bonus when you visit
earnest.com
whitney to refinance your student loans
not available in all states terms and
conditions apply oh and if you have any
questions you can talk to a real person
for help i asked the earnest helpline if
i should buy this tiara
and they said
absolutely not
but i decided to buy it anyway because
i've been broken out of the cycle of
student loan debt i've had this tiara in
my cart for 10 years so i decided to
finally buy it thanks ernest now i can
finally be happy because contrary to
fake news money really can buy you
happiness okay you've had items in your
cart for 10 years how many tabs you have
open on your computer shut up whitney
i'm rich now stop feeling overwhelmed by
student loan payments and start getting
to use your money to buy the stuff you
actually want visit earnest.com whitney
for more details terms and conditions
apply earnest loan refinancing made by
earnest operations llc nmls number
1204917 california financing law license
number 605-4788-535
mission street san francisco california
visit earnest.com licenses for a full
list of licenses does this mean you guys
are going to stop borrowing my clothes
no no obviously not just calm down but
you can always buy them back on ebay
whenever you want
thanks
you're welcome
are we rolling can we go guys
benton
who are we waiting on
uh i'm ready to record the next ad i'm
not sure where emily and grace are
they're supposed to be here by now
what's happening benton have you seen
emily
ads like 10 minutes ago where are they i
don't know they said they're sick or
something what do you mean they're sick
they look fine yesterday you know they
told me that they didn't feel good that
they can't get out of bed
okay what's kind of where they
started feeling sick the day after the
new brooklyn and sheets came in what i
thought winky dink
hey guys
okay we have ads to do you have to get
out of bed when he's waiting no
don't tell whitney
yeah we're just testing the new brooklyn
and loungewear we're actually working
and pajamas we're doing research can't
you tell her that we have like really
bad cramps or something guys guys let's
go ads we're shooting ads what's
happening where are you in my bed
my side oh thank god i'm wearing this
comfortable brooklyn loungewear with no
zippers what is this an italian soccer
game what's with all this drama
ah my head oh i need to lay it down on
the brooklyn pillowcase for like an hour
or two probably can you guys stop this
is just like becoming a charlie in the
chocolate factory nightmare can we just
work from this cloud of brooklyn and
comfort and bed first of all i bought
you standing desks you wanted standing
desks we got them on amazon and now you
want to work from bed all of a sudden
okay that's easy for you to say because
you're the one with the robe yeah a robe
is like a standing bed
second of who'ses yes i'm in the
brooklyn robe and it's like a it's like
a mattress that that is um it's like
being you served in a brooklyn and cozy
mattress cloud all the time
i can sleep standing up while i'm
walking no
can't we just work from this luxuriously
outfitted and brooke linen bed remotely
for today okay you guys bring the sheets
into the studio
make a bed studio is that okay okay
bring the sheets okay bring the sheets
and just bring the sheets into the
studio we'll do it from the studio with
the sheets yeah we're right behind you
you crazy bag and
and all right so i i finally got
them to come into the studio to do these
ads but as you can see they're in
they have to be in brooklyn and
comforters at all times grace we were
not able to
no but go on get comfortable and get it
for less at brook lennon go to
brooklyn.com and use promo code whitney
to get 20 off with a minimum purchase of
a hundred dollars they have over 75 000
five star reviews and counting that's
b-r-o-o-k-l-i-n-e-n.com and enter promo
code whitney for 20 off with a minimum
purchase of a hundred dollars that's
brooklyn.com promo code whitney you guys
better watch those when you're done
those are my actual sheets and
comforters like i sleep in these things
don't look at them i think you're
getting them back you look like the
weirdest cocoon person
no cursing i look freaking adorable
it is true
now let's get back to uh a conversation
that's not adorable with rosebud baker
you seem to have such a um
um
i don't want to i hate it when people
say this i hate when people say strong
woman because then it implies that most
women aren't strong you know i just hate
that shit really you're just saying i'm
loud
but i almost said you're like i hate
when people say like oh you're like the
cool girl like cool it's like oh they're
all cool it's just so if you cheat on us
we get less cool all of a sudden yeah
but you seem very um
in uh a powerlessness and surrender
that's like what am i gonna do like
that's not worth it like you understand
how to um you know the uh i don't
remember what general um said this i'm
probably gonna quote a confederate
leader and get in trouble because it
might have been robert e lee but
sometimes the most um
the most masterful uh move in battle is
a calm retreat it's to just go like i'm
not the best case scenario is to just
like back out of this thing it's not
even worth starting the war i know how
this ends yeah i do get i although i
will say i do get upset when something
is like so obvious where i'm like
i would almost rather like
like if he's like texting with an ex or
something i'm like can you just cheat
can you please just go cheat would that
be easier for you though because of the
black and white yeah you don't know yeah
i wouldn't have to wonder yeah
no not even i just wouldn't know like
and trust me i'm not thinking about you
so much yeah that i
would be like is he cheating i'm like
just go my thing with that is go cheat
never tell me yeah so that you have to
live with the secret and just get a
cancer ball
and then you get cancer later just don't
tell me i don't want to know well that
doesn't work for marriage because then i
inherit his debt oh no
but i'm like go cheat don't tell me but
now it's just like hot people that are
greedy just like it's very hot couples
you know what it is it's like we're open
and i'm like fuck you i just want to
stop my feet and lean yeah but also like
what
you're also implying you narcissism
you're also implying that you're so hot
and gorgeous that someone would just
want to fuck you once and never see you
again right
like that's how much value you add you
better be so good at sex if you're in an
open relationship
and you have a girlfriend and you're
going to come you have to be so good
because what's in it for me otherwise
right
yeah i mean i can't think yeah unless i
just love to like uh cut myself for like
you know i can't think of anything that
would be beneficial i'm so sorry about
the vaping i'm the worst i don't care at
all it makes it like cool and sexy okay
i'm very into it it makes me as long as
you're cool with it because some people
are so grossed out by it but by vaping
yeah
yeah why
because it's
gross i guess i don't have no idea i
mean people just like there have been
times actually where i've been like on a
road trip i blow the vape smoke and the
person in the passenger seat is just
like
and i'm like okay i i'm sorry i'll drive
the car into a river but i don't buy it
i do though cause i it's they'll be in
the middle of a story i'll be in the
middle of they'll be in the middle of a
story and they'll choke on the vape
smoke and i'm sometimes i'm like oh shut
up but other times i'm like oh that's
really that into my face right now okay
see if i choke
i think this person is a faker
nothing i'm fine yeah all right stop
hanging out with pussies who are these
people yeah we're these monsters that
was a lot actually for me you're people
that are like uh
uh hey stranger yeah you do hang out
with them
you can't handle a vape yeah i guess not
everybody i mean we grew i grew up with
like smokers in a house yeah we would
smell like my parents would smoke with
the windows up in the car
yeah my mom was a smoker and uh
she would always hide it she was always
like secretive about it too yeah mine
too i thought that was so sexy how she
would just be like i'm gonna sneak it it
also is so cute that like you think we
don't that you think we don't know like
i feel like yeah it's so funny what you
think you're getting away with yeah you
know especially when you're an active
addiction yeah and then you see other
people do it and you're like i love that
you think i just can't see you put that
in your pocket that's another thing that
uh my therapist said to me he goes
everybody can see you
he goes whatever it is you think that
you're hiding everyone can see it and i
which is our dream yeah everyone sees us
yeah yeah and i just thought oh good
like
great it was such a relief
everyone can see you and nobody's
thinking about you is that those are the
two things that i uh i lean on all the
time where i'm like
you don't have to pretend because
everyone can see it anyway and also um
no one is thinking about me no like of
course that came from my mom and so it
was hurtful from her but
i'm like my mom and dad both said that
um but
as an adult
who works in entertainment
i'm like nobody's thinking about you
like no one's mad at you no one's like
thinking about the thing that you said
and if they are they're psychotic so
just who cares and um
you know neil brennan uh this kicks up
so many things that i i want to say but
i'm trying to uh talk a little bit less
if that's possible but um
i that's so funny on your own podcast
neil brennan
i'm trying i'm like i feel like i'm just
excited to know you and talk to you and
i just need to just be cool and have
faith that we'll talk again after this
at some point yes um or not which is why
i'm gonna hang out here because i
literally have nowhere near that's right
you're staying after okay good what if
this went poorly that'd be awkward
i'm just helping them clean up
downstairs like hanging out in the
kitchen um wait oh neil brennan did this
uh on his instagram once this was ages
ago he did a little song
about how we obsess about how other
people are thinking about us constantly
and that everybody's mad at us all the
time and he and i sing the song when i
obsess about somebody thinking about me
it goes nobody's mad at you nobody's mad
at you you're having a private
experience
nobody's mad at you nobody's mad at you
nobody really gives a fuck
like it's just such a stupid especially
neil singing it because he knows you
know so curmudgeonly he's like nobody's
mad
nobody gives uh fuck nobody says fuck is
just so
no one cares yeah
nobody cares but yes my therapist said
to me once i've said it before on this
podcast but when uh she's like um
uh you know allanon's aca's uh
codependents we obsess over what people
think about us totally realize they're
not so when you leave a conversation
you're like that was stupid he probably
thinks i'm such an idiot either they
think the conversation went fine because
they're normies they're well adjusted
they're moving on to their next
challenge in their day right or
they're thinking they fucked up the
conversation they're having the same
thing you're having yeah you're both in
your preoccupied attachment strategy um
or they're yeah not thinking about you
at all yeah and you might have nailed it
you have a female therapist mm-hmm okay
i i see like under i see a small italian
man okay yeah i was i'm into that where
where did you find this in brooklyn okay
yeah like eight years ago i kind of love
that i love it too the idea that it's
just like a italian like mafia guy who's
like what's the problem yeah
i mean he's literally like um he's just
like this little tough
italian guy love who like never i've
never seen him with shoes on great i've
never seen him with shoes he's always
just done yard work he literally comes
downstairs in
like
his i see him in his house
and everybody who
every other therapist i've ever had was
like in an office with a clipboard this
is like a guy's house in brooklyn he
might not be a therapist sure sure
honestly he might just be an italian guy
who like runs this out of his house yes
i i've been in there we've watched uh
we've watched dog whisperer videos to
try to
for me to try to deal with people like
he's just showing me dog whisperer
videos and i'm like do you
do are you a doctor
or are you just a guy
are we just together i'm like fully
thinks you're in a relationship yeah i'm
just like i'm you've been going on dates
yeah
you're dating my flips upstairs i miss
gumar i swear to god i'm like i don't
care i'm still going to see you bye he's
like helped me i'm like i don't care but
i do think that is kind of amazing
because my therapist who i've now
stopped
connecting her to people because now
she's so busy that she's on time for me
right um and but she's like what's going
on with you that all you're doing is
referring people and not coming yourself
it's like fair
um and uh
she wears pajamas only with uh uh
animals on them trustworthy birkenstocks
with socks trustworthy or crocs like the
pink ones or the tie-dye ones and only
wear shirts with wolves on them amazing
and her office is full of game of
thrones posters and books about guns
oh and she reupholstered all of her
furniture to have um fabric that is uh
tigers
oh my god
i'm seeing so oh she's the best i'm like
she's your bitch she's invisible yeah
she's like 100 yeah she's the only
person who like really tells me
something like is like you're not doing
that i'm like got it right like yes i'm
canceling that show i'm canceling that
job like she's like whatever i i have
i think the reason why i stuck with my
therapist i don't know if you ever did
this but i lied to my therapists all the
time i used to and um this was the first
therapist that i just didn't lie to i
have therapists that think that all my
siblings are alive right in the past
sure
so your therapist that just didn't watch
your specials and she's not a fan of
what you were doing
i'm like this was like before when i had
the i i was able to lie there's nowhere
to look online and i would just i'd be
like yeah everybody's alive and my life
was great and everything's fine i do
think you should title your next special
i have a dead sister
it's just so
savage i mean it's such a savage thing
to have in in your life and
and you brought it up i was like don't
bring it up don't bring it up but it's
tough to segway it is but let me ask you
it's just it's just like
i i one of my best friends uh nick uh he
um who like lives with me most of time
but he watched he had a very uh uh he
watched his brother get killed in front
of him when he was a kid by a car and it
defines him in such a um
intense way i mean when something that
freak happens to you that young right
right it's like that bottle was not her
pulling out xanax because i'm asking
about her dead sister yeah um same
bottle
it defines him on such a fundamental way
because in any given situation he always
assumes the most freak thing will happen
yeah i'm saying it's a catastrophic
thinking that is
earned it deserves yeah you know his
brain has proof that horrible shit will
just happen on two o'clock on a sunday
yeah you know out of freedom so it's
like he'll come in he's like this pen it
says you got to make sure that because
otherwise i could stab someone of it you
know everything is dangerous all the
time
and
i'm just
sort of curious if this is something you
even like want to think about like to
think about just in terms of how it
formed you or impacted you and the
nature versus nurture yeah so
for me it absolutely i'm absolutely a
catastrophic thinker yeah um but there's
also an apathy
that comes from uh
being that way like there's like a is
there any freedom in like the shoe
dropped there's like this kind of um
there's a fearlessness because it's like
the worst thing what are the chances
that something the odds of something
horrible happening to you actually
really go down after something really
horrible has happened yeah so you're
like okay at least i have another like
10 15 years before something else
horrible happens yeah it's like a a
fearlessness and an apathy at the same
time so it's like a fearlessness that
comes from apathy like i
this doesn't matter it doesn't matter so
who cares who cares you know like uh
i i'll give it i'll give advice like
in the same way in that in that way
where it's like my friend was like um
she was like i'm really nervous about
this thing and i was like
you were like a child sex slave you know
what i mean i was just like reminder of
that
and she'll be like what the fuck
and i'm like i thought that was
comforting i just feel like i'm trying
to give you some perspective yeah i mean
maybe you need to go back into the trunk
to
learn what adversity really is like you
know what fear is yeah don't overstep
no
you of all people should know yeah you
know i'm like i thought that was
comforting i thought that when she's
like no that's not that's not how you do
comfort you know that would have totally
worked for me but that's right that's
how i do comfort that's how i comfort
myself is like i'll i literally somebody
uh dm'd me what are you gonna do if the
plane goes down the other day who is
this person and i was like i'm in first
class
that's all i'm gonna think i died in
first class
thank god
you know what i mean that's all i'm
gonna that's all i'm gonna say to myself
i'm not like that
worried about
death uh-huh yeah no i it's so
interesting you say that because i was
talking to a friend of mine the other
day who was talking about
his anxiety on a plane he's like i worry
about the plane's gonna crash and i'm
like okay so how does this manifest he's
like i don't want to get on a plane and
i'm like so this defines you like the
fact that your biggest fear
is something that's so statistically
uh for the most part like not going to
happen right what i'm saying the fact
that that's your focus means you have no
problems
only when you're flying on a plane which
costs at least a couple hundred dollars
to even get on so you're already can get
on a plane
you actually have no problems yeah and
he's like what if a meteor hits the
plane it's almost like what the meteor
hits the plane that's the only thing
less likely than the plane going down by
it but you won't know what's happening
that's the best case scenario you're
just like you'll die you won't feel it
so you're
scared of something you won't even feel
i think that's how addicted to anxiety
this person is and how addicted to
worrying they are that is a very real
addiction i think a lot of people don't
talk about it i think that um
people are the people who are deeply
deeply afraid of death are really just
um afraid of life
and that's really what it is i think
they're afraid of
they don't live their lives to the
fullest extent and so they're terrified
of running out of time because they
didn't do it where did you how did you
i just come upon that i just think that
most of the time if you look at
if you look at a behavior it's always
tied to the opposite of what you think
yeah you know what i mean sure it's like
when someone accuses you of cheating
what are you up to right every time i
cheated i was like who's that who's in
your phone because i was like it was top
of mind for me right and i would project
on to them every you're in the gym while
you're cheating yeah that's what i'm
doing you know it's like you see you
know yeah and it's like cheating
is um you look at cheating as like a uh
something where
somebody's trying to feel something it's
like or because somebody like feels
something for somebody else it's because
it's no they don't they can't feel
anything they don't know how to like
feel and they're doing it to feel alive
it's gambling or it's just to get some
kind of um uh adrenaline rush i'm gonna
feel caught i need to have this secret
what is your definition of cheating what
is cheating now
fucking someone that is my definition of
cheating but there is this emotional
affair thing that i think is a new
kind of conversation that i or i mean
bullshit right it's bullshit there's no
emotional affairs
listen you can
have your there's you can have feelings
for other people yeah
if you're like chatting it up with them
yeah you're you're opening the door or
you're setting the groundwork sorry i
see why there i see why it's an issue
because cheating is the result of uh
multiple things happening first that's
it that's the key because when people go
like oh they just slept with someone
it's no big deal or oh that like i can
get over this if it was just a sexual
thing it's like no in order to get to
that sexual place unless they just met
on an app and agreed to just fuck in a
parking lot or whatever and that sex
addiction that's intrigue that's a whole
other thing um but it's like the amount
that went into that happening right it
took months to cultivate oh yeah it's
like that and so i get why
people go it's an emotional affair it's
like
what you did was you caught them before
they got to cheat yeah
yeah yes yes yeah i would be so easy to
cheat on because he does go into the
bathroom for like two hours a night just
to fart
and
i'm like
it feels like you could be carrying on
an affair but i'm not getting up to find
out crohn's disease i literally he's
like i have ibs he's seen a doctor i'm
like
okay well there's no doctor can help you
with the farting for two hours every
night in the bathroom just to go fart do
you go in the bathroom it doesn't smell
like farts after yeah it does not smell
good it doesn't it smells worse than
that emily weren't you asked to fart in
a video for a guy
or was that a wedgie
okay yeah i i know i would have done it
i got i'm just saying maybe he's farting
for i don't know only fans farting
through underwear is a big ticket really
yup yup wedgies like guys will just dm
and say like seven thousand dollars for
you to give yourself a wedgie okay can i
just say this right now while i have the
platform if you want my underwear
from out of my ass
just dm me i will send it my husband
will co-sign
whatever you guys need i'll
yeah
underwear wedgies are we open for
wedgies
i'm open for wedgies how much to sit on
a cake
what's your price
i mean whatever whatever is more than
the last person you paid to do that
does that work you can't see my feet
because those you'll stop listening no
way i disagree
trust me why what is wrong with you i
was a dancer i have what kind of dancer
were you i was a ballet dancer i'm
obsessed with this really i didn't know
this yeah i was a ballet dancer when did
that start
um
like when once my parents realized i
wasn't good at sports so
you were good at self-harm
yeah yeah and i hated ballet and they
never let me quit and i was just like i
fucking hate this i was like
a little uh i was like a circle a
circle-shaped child and they put me in a
leotard which is child abuse kid in the
90s that was child abuse i have this
whole bit i'm working i'm doing now
about ballet because i i'm
shocked that it's still a thing that's a
business i'm i'm fine with it being a
children's hobby but like being an
actual business is just wild to me you
can never pitch that as a business today
is kind of the thing right but um uh
when kids do it i went to my
goddaughter's ballet recital and they do
have pot bellies yeah at like five six
seven yeah and it is like oddly not
sexual but also just
too naked like i feel uncomfortable
watching about yeah
yeah i mean i i see like i see little
ballet dancers and i'm like i wish
somebody had told me that i was the
cutest one because i was like this
little roly-poly like going out there
and just i looked like a snowman i was
built like a snowman what did you learn
from ballet or how did that shape you
um
i was disciplined you know like i
it taught me discipline and you taught
me physical i do have a physical
awareness
more than other people i've noticed that
like the most of the world does not have
a physical awareness of like where their
body is in a space yeah
how much it's
how your body
um
reacts to people to things i have a very
i'm very aware of like how someone makes
me feel first physically
then emotionally so if i notice my body
going like
you know then i'm like oh somebody i i
gotta like either open up or see what's
going on something's going like the
impact this person is having on me but
are you or just how i feel
in this space right now like you know
intuition
yep my intuition is like really good i
don't and i think that might be why i'm
not as
worried about cheating
because i know when it's happened i knew
when an ex was like fucking somebody
from across the country and i called a
friend and she was like yeah i saw him
with this person
like last night and i was like yep i
don't want to make you do this joke but
it is the
funniest shit
when you were like um that
you fucked me for five years what is it
yeah your dna there's so much dna in my
body that i'll never not know where you
are that is the funniest idea to me it
is so true yeah it's so true like i'll
see
like an ex in a photo and like at a
beach wedding with 40 people and i'm
like he's flirting with her like you
just know yeah it is bizarre yeah no
they'll never it's the the idea that you
can lie to a woman is crazy and you
always know the person they're gonna
date when you break up mm-hmm i always
know yeah i'm like i know the person
that like
you know like sometimes couples who do
this thing where they're like when we
break up here the three people you're
not allowed to date right or something
like that's a really immature childish
thing to do but i always i'm like i knew
it was going to be her i knew it the
whole time you thought i was crazy right
right i always knew you got a crush i
know making those deals is so useless
because it's like if you're having to
make the deal you know it's going to
happen already totally and you're
creating a weird trauma bond adversity
bond between
the very person that you're scared
with so now they already have this like
forbidden thing she did probably or he
doesn't even know what's happening yeah
i'm saying because i've had a lot of
like guys and comedy come up to me and
be like hey my ex said i was never
allowed to talk to you i'm like well
that's the only reason you're talking to
me now yeah because there's some
cause you're into me because you're not
supposed to even i'm into me but yeah
you want to just like live this
adrenaline moment and i just want to be
out of i don't want to be a part of
such a crazy thing to say to somebody
too i know it's like to walk up and be
like hey
i'm not supposed to talk to you no
literally i'm like cool and then the guy
with the doll house on his head is like
hey let's hang out
damn it
the guy with the doll house is like my
ex said i wasn't allowed to wear a
dollhouse on my head
like jesus i just um
i am so impressed by by your
brain and the way that you think and
um thank you you said in your special
that you are with your soulmate what
does that mean what does that word mean
i mean
it's so it was such a non-cynical moment
it was such a like i'm with my soul mate
it was so sincere and so um there's such
a journey with you because because just
when i think as a viewer you're probably
like oh this is dark is she okay she's
like i'm with my soul mate you're like
oh no what's my
oh no you don't want to be in a happy
healthy relationship
that's so funny that almost sounded like
mullany
yeah i
i wanted that moment in there because
i do feel like i'm with my soul mate and
that's not getting into all the
different books but like and all their
different definitions of that but it to
me
uh this is someone that i've never felt
more comfortable being myself with like
i am a hundred percent myself all the
time when he's when he's doing things
that scare me
like
like uh
like he's starting for two hours that
doesn't even scare me honestly i mean i
hope he's okay but i'm like
just most of the time i'm like you're
missing half the shows i'm not pausing
you know how to make a murderer or how
to how to
whatever how to whatever
murder making a murderer yes i'm how to
make a murderer that's a very different
show
it's so funny i i feel like that's the
thing that i mean that made me remember
what he's uh what he's doing that's
bothering me um
is my husband is a hundred percent like
i love you keep going but he also
suffers from depression and he also uh
is also a comic so
when things are going really good for me
i can sense i can feel when when this
when it when he's struggling
and he doesn't even say it like he he
does have the boundaries to keep that to
himself and to deal with those things on
his own and he's in therapy and he's in
recovery and all of that shit so
but because i
deal with like toxic guilt shit
i'll start to feel guilty
is your guilt from the family system or
just from being i don't i mean it's from
everything it's from
just
funny and talented so great um let's
keep it at that yeah but where would you
get your guilt i think
well my sister died at a graduation
party for my high school graduation yeah
so like
sorry
it was your fault
it was in a way it was like it was at a
high school graduation party for my high
school graduation and
she was she wouldn't have been there if
it weren't for me so there's this
immediate and i like changed her into
her bathing suit so i like
it you know when the way that my brain
reacted to the event was
she wouldn't have been there
she i was yeah it was the party was for
me it was for my high school like my
high school graduation um i was 17
yeah
so it was like
i went my whole life like oh that
even though and because i left for
college immediately afterwards i had no
tools i wasn't in therapy i was just
drinking i was like so all i had i had
all the trauma like settle in
before
i was even gonna go there and that's why
i have so many therapists that think i
have
four living sisters because i would go
into therapy and i'd be like we're not
gonna talk about that like i'm not gonna
touch that well what's there to say
there's no way to like it's just like
where do you even start there's nowhere
to start there's no getting over it yeah
you can't they're you there i'm so i
know you went to harvard and i know that
you have all these degrees you can't
help me yeah you can't that's like
you just can't like that's the thing
with this kind of grief it's like yeah
we can like
a lot of times when you talk about it
too much you're reinventing the trauma
you have some story about it but it's
like unless it's some kind of like emdr
or like serious trauma recovery yeah
like what are you gonna do for me yeah i
mean i had besides prescribed me fucking
delauden for six years right i i had to
go to i mean this guy uh that i see now
it was all like
punching pillows screaming yelling
getting it out of my body so i had to
fight something until i cried yeah and
that was like how i recovered from
like this deep deep grief that i held in
my body
for
so long i mean i i didn't go into
therapy
over what had happened to my sister
until i was at least six years sober and
i didn't think i was going for that i
thought i was going to save the
alcoholic that i was with so i was
really trying to save the life of
someone
who
because i hadn't saved hers so it was
all like projection and all that
so
when i when good things are happening
for me and things and i'm on the
precipice of big change i immediately
start to tense up
i start to reenact this feeling of like
i'm gonna have to leave the people that
i love behind
in a way that will they're gonna fall
apart so if i
yeah i have all this projection around
that and even though the person that i'm
with is not putting any of that on to me
if i can sense it
i i have to work really really hard
not to
act out the way that i want to act out
which is like
keep myself small
or
minimize yourself or hide your
accomplishments or hide your light or
whatever all that which is you know such
a like a human instinct obviously with
what you've been through and stuff like
that too but it's like it doesn't serve
other people when we turn down our
volume like it doesn't make them
stronger or better like because then
they never get the two because we're
just accommodating their
bullshit they're bullshit yeah and we're
just enabling ultimately so it's like
the best thing you know but this is why
i think when i go to he's my soul mate
i'm like i can
i can do this like i can do this with
this guy we are both working enough on
our own shit
to make this work even though we
struggle and it's to me
that's all i wanted out of a
relationship with someone to be fully
themselves
to
to want to expand in multiple ways
spiritually sexually physically uh
mentally
emotionally
and financially and um
and i see that happening with him even
in the midst of like
thing uh struggling and i'm like
that's it that's what i want you know
and of course
there's moments where things are
happening for me that aren't going to
happen for him there's things that are
happening for him that aren't happening
by the way but that
sorry to interrupt uh but it's like
that's going to happen whether you're
dating a comedian or not or married to a
comedian yeah because if you just worked
at a
in chipotle he'd still it would be about
you know some other comedian or some
other you know what i'm saying like
comedians by nature we have this you
know we need to and we're wired to do
this as a species anyway when we move
into a room um uh anytime we move into a
new space and new people we have to rank
ourselves to see what is make us safe if
there's a fire who to follow who's the
alpha like it's like something we're
wired to do regardless whether you're
married to a you know a rising star
comedian or not i mean i always think
that to myself whenever i'm like
frustrated with him i'm like why am i
acting like this wouldn't be happening
with somebody else
i'm like this would be happening with
whoever i'm with because these are the
challenges that i deal with and i have
to focus on my part of the issue yeah
and if you weren't with him it'd be some
guy that was like so you just hang out
with male comics all the time so your
opener's a guy so who you're just with
in a hotel room with this guy where's
the male comics like oh yeah i know
you're not dating him he's the worst you
know what i mean like it should be a
different right sort of set of
circumstances yeah but it is the
alcoholic brain of i'd believe i deserve
to be having fun all the time and have
no conflict in my relationship ever ever
ever because then i have to be
uncomfortable god forbid so it's like or
like which by the way that's a
terrifying person who's like oh yeah no
i don't have conflict yeah yeah i mean
well i also am so wired to i think i've
cr over corrected the other way because
i was so preoccupied with other people's
needs or my perception of what their
needs were for so long that now when
anyone has any needs i'm like
like that's for you to take care of
that's not my problem before i solve a
problem i need to first make sure it's
my problem this is not my problem and
i'm not gonna enable you and you do that
too it's like i i'm over programmed
sometimes and i can't just let go and be
like okay i'll do this for you
yeah the it's like a counter dependence
kind of thing or it's also just like a
trying so it's a rigidity it's trying so
hard to not do anything codependent that
you're kind of just being
confrontational i get into a lot of
arguments like that where i'm like the
self-righteous i did the right thing i
set a boundary for myself you can't
accept my back like i and then you go
you know what i could win this yeah but
if i win we both lose yeah and also like
if i'm thinking about winning it's
already i've already lost right i'm like
do i really understand what he's
actually trying to say why can't i just
i'll get really caught up on the syntax
yeah where i'm like well it's the way
the way that you said this and he's like
but that's
that's what my problem is with what you
did and i'm like okay so we have the
same problem i understand what you're
saying i can just do whatever and also
like i can keep doing this for my ego or
like for some kind of bullshit score
you know that nobody's keeping like no
one like pops out of a closet and gives
you a check for 10 grand every time you
win on a formality with your own
boyfriend you know what i mean i know
sometimes i know you win a house i know
i sometimes feel the way um
sometimes like i i'll be so strict with
myself and i'll be so like focused
and goal-oriented that i'm like what am
i hillary clinton like what why why am i
acting like this you know i'm not
i feel like i'm just
trying to like check off things and i
like try to like be there i'm like
if you're like writing be there for your
for your husband or your boyfriend or
your partner on your list of to do's
like
there might be there might be some room
for flexibility you know
call auntie right yeah
it's literally like call home
like sometimes
like sometimes he'll be like uh
he'll just say to my friend uh hey if
you talk to my wife tell her to come
home which is just his way of like
fucking with me i love because
because he knows like i'm
i'm just like out of there i'm not yeah
yeah i think he's not on my mind yeah i
think that's that to me is like like i i
don't know what love is necessarily i've
you know and of how to define it um or
soulmate whatever but i do know a friend
of mine jane marie once said
she's like um was in a relationship
she's like the relationship is like so
amazing because when i'm with him i'm so
happy but when i'm not around him i just
don't think about him yeah and to me
that is someone that's bringing out the
best version in you because you're not
constantly preoccupied with them you're
not defined through them you're not
obsessing about them because when we
obsess about other people it's not fair
to them because we put in too much
emotional work so if they
do one thing that's not up to you know
uh our standard of how we want to be
treated like why just how could you do
it like i'm giving more to this yeah no
one asked he didn't ask you to obsess
about him for seven hours straight you
did that right and now
you're you're basically and that's why
that's um a lot of people don't talk
about the addiction of intrigue
addiction like when we obsess over
people and the the mental addiction of
you know there's a lot of parasocial
relationships like this where people are
in relationships with like famous people
that know you know and it's a way to
stay out of a real relationship to just
be in a fake one with someone um yeah
and or someone in your office or someone
you know in your purview somehow but we
also do it with people we're in
relationships with and then when we
actually hang out with them it's like
who are you're not the person that i've
been with for the last eight hours in my
head right
at all
yes i look the most
like a pharmaceutical sales rep of
anyone
in this town i mean i do i look like a
multi-level marketing like
guru i look like the biggest mlm queen
in saint louis
with this hair i don't know what to do
you're putting up numbers
like what even is this dude i my hair
was that for my special and i'm so upset
about the way it is i love your hair and
you're special it does not look good i
loved everything you did in your special
i don't i love your outfit was fantastic
it is important sorry yeah like we're
talking about girls outfits i talk about
guys too
um i wish i was wearing a t-shirt that's
the only thing i love what you were like
white like thermal kind of thing yeah i
loved it thank you because i
i obviously was like what do i it is
important i agree so important because
you know what the idea is to be able to
like illuminate your character but not
distract and not be uncomfortable so
comedians i think make
i always see this mistake where and i've
made it myself many times where you
always wear sneakers and jeans on stage
and that's what you're comfortable doing
then you have your special you're like
well i'm gonna wear heels in a dress and
it's oh i've never done stand up in
heels in a dress yeah and now all of a
sudden i'm weird enough and i feel like
i'm trying to impress people at a party
you know what i mean there's a weird
different so yeah i did i knew that i
wanted to wear
jeans and some shirt just some
non-descript shirt and like sneakers and
uh and i did but i was like so
i was still uncomfortable and i was like
i should have worn a t-shirt i should
have worn her t-shirt really yeah i
loved i have to be honest with you i
loved that it was long sleeve because
there's something so gangster about long
sleeve shirt long sleeve pants and it
was just very much like i'm here to do
comedy and like i stopped thinking about
your outfit yeah after 10 seconds yeah
yeah that's good because if i if your
arms i'd be looking at your watch you
know what i'm saying like it just would
have been
yeah i always want the thing that i'm
wearing to be like
nothing
but it doesn't matter because
people will make something out of it
people will if
people will always comment on the outfit
so i'm just like all right if it's gonna
be if if somebody's gonna comment on it
they're gonna be saying the same thing
over and over again and whoever is like
speaking up is just gonna sound hacky
but you know what it was i think the
most important thing it was just
timeless in 40 years someone can watch
that special yeah and uh
that will still be in style do you know
what i'm saying or you know like that's
what i'm a lot of people
you know don't know about friends this
is not the reason friends got syndicated
it's a brilliant show and the writing
was amazing and the performances are
great um and the chemistry was there
like like once in a lifetime lightning
in a bottle of chemistry but the
wardrobe people if you're going to make
a show that you want to get syndicated
you don't dress characters in super high
fashion trendy stuff you test them they
the customer said we dressed them like
german tourists yeah
yeah even today you look at what they're
wearing and it's kind of norm core it's
like khaki shorts and a white tank top
t-shirt and jeans like it still works so
it's like you can watch it now and not
be like oh this was obviously 20 years
ago like you kind of just get right you
get it it's not distracting so i for
people and their specials like what you
did was you made it so in 20 years it's
still gonna just hold up and look cool
not be distracted yeah and that's that's
like i was like i want people to focus
on the fucking jokes because i i've
worked on these jokes for nine years i'm
like this is my first special
i loved that it was the it was a chance
to do a special and from in front of an
audience that didn't know who i was
and that is like
you only have your first special to do
that
and i was like i wanted to make a joke
out of that i wanted to open on that i
wanted to you know i wanted to like
there's like all this anticipation that
i was feeling yeah but i was like let's
check in outside you know what i mean
it's like yeah yeah let's see what's
going on outside and they're all like
yeah i don't know who she is yeah and
then uh had my husband be like
just do like a cameo you know so that
people who do know who i am would be
like oh get what you're doing sure yeah
um
and i wanted all those moments that
people
will comment like i don't understand why
the guy at the end why they why she kept
the guy at the end because there's i
mean look this is okay so there what i
loved about your special is it was uh
not only well written brilliant
insightful like fresh new like
i mean we've been doing community so
long i mean there's you've heard every
version of a premise and then i'd hear
you do it and i was like i've never
heard that like that's the that's the
only joke that's the only rape whistle
joke
thank you it's over like there's no more
thank you like she got she has it she
got it like it's it's over
and so um
and that was like just so exciting to
see like as even as a comedian to be
surprised by someone's mind and it's not
like i'm so it's just more like you've
just seen so much you normally can sort
of see where someone's going and it was
like holy shit like i felt like i just
could be a comedy fan
and just watch comedy and like really
just be on the ride um so i can only
imagine how
you know um dazzling the experience will
be for non-comedians but um but you it
does kind of
um
grind my gears but not in an intense way
maybe nettle me when you watch a special
there's like a four minute video in the
beginning and there's it's like well
there's a stand up like right we can do
this on your instagram that felt like an
ig story yeah that felt like a snapchat
yeah but yours like
like there was um
because uh basically people uh that are
coming to the show they'll ask about you
and it's their real reactions yeah at
first i had a defensiveness i was like
don't do this you're like this is your
moment this is your special like shine
like don't you know but
it really did um
make me realize how defensive i was and
how much that hit a nerve and then and
then uh uh at the end there's a guy who
says basically like i feel like she was
forcing it yeah she's trying to be edgy
she's trying to be i basically was like
cut that she's stupid and then my brain
was like you know what no because that's
exactly what happens and she's not
pretending it doesn't yeah and
there's nothing
sicker to me
than in a good way positive sick is that
if you've enjoyed it and don't agree
with that at all yeah you're gonna go
holy shit that's what she has to contend
with like that's what some people took
away from this and then if you did think
that
you then go oh i'm just an asshole like
this guy well there's two yeah there's
two reasons it's very
confrontational in a good way there's
two reasons why i did it the first
reason is that it's my dad
and he really wanted to be on it
no i just i find it funny like
every time you have a moment that's like
really important to you and something
goes wrong
that's what makes me laugh so i was like
let's put it in love it um the guy in
the middle of the show that was like i
was like are you having a good time and
he was like no i was like
keep it in
i was like i wanted those moments to
stay in because
why should i have to
i shouldn't have to control every funny
thing that happens in my special there's
funny things that happen that i wanted
to keep in because they were just
like they were just gold to me yeah like
comedic gold is like yeah failing is so
funny yeah and uh
and then only successful people can do
that do you know what i'm saying yeah
yeah only
it's almost like
you know because in my brain it was a
little bit like don't leave that in if
people are just discovering her i don't
want them to and it's like no everyone
knows if you're able to have that
exchange yeah it means you've done this
a billion times without that exchange
right and also like i'm saying it also
means that it doesn't bother me like it
doesn't it's not
it's not a bad thing for somebody not to
like you it's like also if you're good
at what you do you don't give a shit
it's also okay to have a little fun in
your special yeah like like that one was
for me yeah like there's a couple jokes
and like specials where i'm like goddamn
this is not
special quality like it's not working
it's super inconsistent this joke or
this whatever but it makes me laugh and
if it's a joke to you guys but just
funny to me it's gonna
keep me up oh yeah in the moment yeah
there was a joke that i did about um the
opioid crisis where i was like nobody's
gonna like it would work 50 of the time
but it's so fucking funny to me that i
was like i don't give a shit yeah yeah
i'm keeping this in yeah like if you
don't think this is funny you're not for
me and i'm not for you and like
i that's how i see it but also
the other reason i kept it in is like
i just um
i wanted to see i knew it was going on
the internet and the internet needs an
enemy
and so i fed them an enemy and also that
is
so smart that is truly like on some
ninja warrior shit because it is
you know to me and i literally was
you know we are going to get through
this podcast without talking about
cancel culture it's not going to come up
we're not going to discuss it because
comedians are creating it because it's
all comedians talk about three people
said like can you stop saying the n word
another like my first amendment right
comedians have blown this out of
proportion it is so ridiculous to me but
um
but it's kind of like
i think all the people that are going
through that it's like well you've never
called yourself out on anything it's
like you you can't get god if you
already got yourself you're already
going like hey here's the the bullshit
mm-hmm
yeah so there's no point giving you
bullshit because so much of of of you
know uh negativity that people get
is let me just like
say this thing that no one else is that
every time someone makes a joke about my
last name i'm like you truly think
you're the first person
yeah to make a cum joke about my last
i'm 39 years old it's like
but if you take away their ability to
think that they might be the first
person to do it yeah and make them feel
unoriginal there's nothing to troll
right it's like oh man
yeah i just kind of wanted to um
i was like i know that i know that
there's going to be people
saying these things
if if this is what they're saying in
person
then they're going to be saying it on
the fucking internet and so why don't i
just show them what it really looks like
you know then it's interesting um
but also like that guy sorry to insult
you if you're watching sir i'm sure he
follows everything you do now he's yeah
no he's absolutely obsessed and so uh
yeah like now that he's famous for that
it's also kind of like
sorry but he's like kind of old and
dorky it's like it's an old dorky take
yeah
yeah because also there was something
that i i felt the need to bring up about
didn't it say she tried too hard is that
what you said yeah she's trying too hard
to be edgy and she doesn't need to do
that she's a very funny lady when she's
a very funny lady when did trying hard
become no he said i was a very funny
girl or something i i think anyway
whatever he said was like
uh yeah and
yes off of what you're saying trying too
hard to be edgy you guys paid money i'm
gonna try hard that was the deal here
yeah i mean
i don't
i know what he thinks he's saying but i
do no guy gets that
he just tries too hard well it was it
was that was interesting because i don't
think he knows that what he's saying is
very gendered but it but it was
and so i just wanted to show
like
you know this is this is this is what it
is yeah and also like fuck you a little
bit and i'm gonna roll credits over you
and i'm gonna keep the part in where you
fall in the street because
because that's what you deserve you know
what i mean and i hope that i i kept out
the part where you got run over by a car
and
that's i'm decent and then i squirt it
uncontrollably
because i like watching my trolls get
injured
um i
i love what you're this what you're
doing is also so um i'm sorry it's sort
of impossible for me to look at this
without seeing sort of like you know the
you talk in your special about having
like an addictive mindset an addict
mindset yeah i i'm obsessed with talking
about stuff like that because i think
it's so pathologized in a way that's not
deserved i think addict mindsets are
actually incredibly uh advantageous um
you know i think there's you have the
disease of addiction you're an adequate
as long as we can sort of sublimate our
addiction into something positive or
find no one's more unstoppable than a
sober addict no yeah there's nobody
that's going to win harder yeah so like
there's always like people whether
they're interviewing for things they're
like i just didn't want to tell you that
i'm a recovery i'm like dude you're
hired yeah you're saying yes an addict
looking for a new addiction or a drug
like the
the focus the sort of like you know um
to me you know the addictive brain
evolved as uh you know an advantage it
used to be like i mean 2000 years ago if
you walk by a raspberry bush and just
took one
in two miles you're gonna starve to
death but if you're the person who's
like that's not enough one too many i'm
gonna have nine thousand raspberries and
i'm gonna put a bunch of my pocket i'm
not gonna share them with anybody else
and then i'm gonna hide more of it like
that's the person that's gonna survive
and procreate yeah so it actually was an
evolutionary advantage so it's like i
see it i see it as
a superpower i'm just and as you're
saying like leaving in that guy is such
the opposite um
of sick addictive thinking but i did
want to kind of run a couple things by
you just in terms of the way
that
you know addictive thing it never gets
cured you're in recovery because you
don't cure it you just maintain it right
and you develop the neural pathways to
be able to resist and and self-soothe
other ways or tolerate the discomfort
but there are little
you know it's whack-a-mole yeah and then
i have all these just weird addictive
things that i just want to talk to you
about now
because i feel like you would get it
yeah
eating in the grocery store
is one of the most addict-y things i do
i can't wait
i do that a lot i do in the car
it
sometimes but i'll do it in the store
yeah me too yeah especially with olives
if there's an olive thing i'd go to all
this open olive thing yeah no i mean
i'll go to the olive bar fill it with
olives eat olives while i'm going down
and just watch my face blow up i'm
obsessed with this i
am so not a germaphobic person i do not
care i clean sh my horse's shit and with
my hands and i clean his dick without
gloves like that
i didn't even know you were supposed to
use gloves i just scratch out all the
black goo of his shaft and it's like in
my nails
it is so and i have no i have no qualms
about it i do not think it is gross i
look at it i smell it i'm like feeling
but like don't care what olives in a bin
at the grocery store i just am like i
don't i can't
what can't
what is the the cognitive dissonance
between because i'm not putting it in my
mouth it's not cum i don't make him calm
i don't check
horse
dick cheese stick cheese that's slack
it's not it's it's mold is that what
it's called
no dick mold
horse crust
okay dong jelly so you're going to try
to make this sound better but it doesn't
go in my mouth
yeah okay okay okay it doesn't go in
your mouth but if you're smelling it
yeah yeah
those molecules go in my nose which are
also attached to your mouth right
why are you also like tasting a little
bit of what you're smelling such a
strong immune system
i don't know i had covered i can't taste
or smell anything for eight months now
you would never i literally want to take
you to a to a grocery store right now to
like for like exposure are you one of
those people that eats like ceviche out
of one of those buffets i don't eat
ceviche at all i don't eat fish because
they don't have hair on them and they're
they look the same dead as they do alive
it's weird okay i don't want to make it
my contestations have hair
lobsters have hair and they have nerve
endings in them
disgusting
fucking gross read what is it uh uh the
l what is it the david foster wallace
book uh the case for the lobster where
he you'll never eat lobster again not
that i ever did but um
see arachnids they have
sea
porcupines they've got yeah they've got
a protective shell
um like us and a little bit of our own
hair
tiny bit fair but so fish look the same
dead and alive is that that's what yeah
i don't like the way that the like when
i when you put a fish down in front of
somebody
they look
and sm and smell the same dead as they
did alive interesting and i'm like how
the fuck are you if you put an actual
cow in front of me i'm not gonna eat it
there's no ability to pretend it's not a
cow a cow
but if it's uh when did this start
since i was a kid wow fascinating i
still can't like let go of it sure no
raw fish no cooked fish
no no fish nothing
fascinating no
and then okay what are do you have any
other things that now that you have um
uh you maintain your primary uh sort of
qualifying addiction other little things
uh
i do that are addicted do you have any
texting and driving i still find myself
doing it
um my phone texts people back
immediately
that says like do not disturb because
i'm driving put it somewhere i have to
put my phone in a purse in the back seat
yeah i just turn it over and then my
phone will automatically respond i'm
driving do not disturb or whatever
which is great if you're driving but if
you're in an uber and your friend is
like hey i'm you know i'm really
suffering and things really aren't going
the way i planned and i just i don't
feel like just right back hey stranger
and it just writes no it literally my
phone my phone will be like do not
disturb
my phone
if somebody's reaching out for help my
phone will be like
stop you're disturbing i'm driving stop
disturbing her okay you might want to
kill yourself don't kill us both
it's literally like it's so rude it's so
cheap it is so rude i can't figure out
how to turn it off but i i think it
might be saving my life so i just was
like i'm broke i have no money it's like
i don't want to end it i know but a
rosebud is driving we get it you have a
car we're not
yeah i'm busy
it's so
funny
i do not i should do that but let me
tell you something if i if that if that
was not on i would absolutely be texting
and driving it's just like a it's it's
having to be alone with my own thoughts
and then the magical thinking of oh
we're not moving oh i can just send one
text and once i send one i'm like oh
well i'm a wizard mm-hmm you know i can
text without looking and last time i did
it nothing happened and then oh i'm
gonna do voicemail the way that i
rationalize justify is absolutely you
know uh exactly the way i would with a
with a substance because like oh no i'll
do a voice memo which is like which is
alcoholics going i'll only drink rose
there is though i do get so afraid when
my husband will be driving and looking
at his phone
and he does it so much
that i remember one time like i won't
say anything i won't say anything i
won't say anything or i'll be like
please don't text and drive please don't
text and drive and then he was doing it
one time and i had held it in for so
long that day that i just took his phone
and just threw it in the back and just
like i was like i'm your map and then so
but wait how many times did he do it
before you said something i don't know
it was enough times that i i
without being able to control myself
reached over and chucked it in the back
because but i'm obsessed with all the
times you didn't say something
yeah i mean
i was hoping that
i i was hoping i would keep better track
because then i could i could give myself
credit for the way that i
did what i did interesting interesting
but i just didn't i wasn't keeping track
i was just like so fine like that's fine
too when i'm like i'm not going to pick
this fight so that later i feel pride
that i didn't pick this fight whatever
it takes yeah to not take the action
whatever it takes to just don't do
something sit there
i'll do
um
one it was just this one day where i was
just like fuck this yeah the same thing
happened one one time he wouldn't shut
the fuck up he just kept complaining
about something and i was trying to give
him good advice and he was like just
kept complaining i in the middle of what
he was saying hit my head and this is on
the scene just went shut the fuck up and
then he stopped the car and i walked
into the woods i just got out and and
when i say woods i mean like echo park
but like i just left the car and was
like goodbye
and just was like i can't do this
and just laugh uh-huh and like
was like go and i was like i walked home
uh-huh later because i just showed him i
just couldn't do it do it and it drove
me crazy sometimes you just have to
remove yourself from the situation and i
think
the the struggle i have now is my duties
like we're giving the silent treatment
i'm like i'm actually just
trying to not say all the things that i
have in my head that i want to say right
now because it will change the way you
view yourself forever
like we will never
the things that i
think are a good idea to say right now
will destroy
your sense of self and your ability to
be a father and also it's like stuff
that
and then your ability to protect our
family you will never
go through life again so it's like let
me just take a walk let me have a a day
i usually need a day a couple days let
me call a couple people
let me just go on raya to make sure it's
all still guys with v-necks and man buns
like let me just get my perspective
realize how lucky i am to be with you
and that my disease wants me to sabotage
this my disease wants me to be right
and that
doesn't go great yeah i mean i
definitely um
i have a habit of
like
building a case against someone that
doesn't know that they're on trial
and then uh
and then i can't take back what i've
said because i do mean it because i mean
i mean it and then if i've said it
i'm going to defend i'm going to stand
by it yeah i said what i said and i
didn't mean it at the time i don't lie i
meant it at the time yeah when i had
that hormonal balance and that
adrenaline when i was drunk on
adrenaline and
be feeling like a victim or whatever
um but also it's true
and you and now
i have to defend something because i
because it is true but i'm not the
person that should say this yes that's
right that's right that's right
this is i don't want to have to have
been the person to tell you this like
yeah but i don't have time to wait
around for your mom that caused this
problem to become self-aware enough to
tell you about it right but i think that
uh let me ask you when do you know
when do you come for in a relationship
when do you compromise and when do you
hold your ground and i know that sounds
combative but
but when do you know
yeah you know what i know what you mean
the slide and when you go you know what
i have to fight for this because it's
going to set a precedent and it's going
to become toxic if i don't just
do something about it now this is a when
does quote relationships take work i
can't understand these concepts and i
need you to explain it to me okay so i
think of it the same way that like if i
want mexican food but i also want
italian food i just decide which one do
i want more and i go how much more
farting tonight do i want to do exactly
no no this is just as myself just as an
individual i go with the thing that i
want more whichever matters more to me
so as a couple
if something clearly matters more to him
than it does to me i'll i'll compromise
but if something matters more to me than
it does to him
i stand my ground sure so that's how i
sort of that's the math that i use even
if
it mattering to them
seems dumb
yeah which most of the time is that
listen there was that's where i that i'm
like okay so you're fantasy football so
i have to like
this shouldn't ma so when do you decide
that you don't get to decide what
matters
what i'm saying so do you know what i
mean because i know
when something
it's a beach volleyball league mm-hmm
yeah i'm not moving my flight this is
getting so specific
i no longer know what's happening in the
area rocks that go nowhere
i know this is important to you but do
you know how weird that is okay so i had
a i had an argument with andy a couple
weeks ago we went to a wedding i got us
a hotel
uh we got to the hotel
they showed us a room
and then he found out
that there was a yurt on the property
and i go outside i let him check in and
he's like hey i changed our room we're
in the yurt and i go
i got us a room
and he was like yeah but we're in the
yurt now
and the way that he was
that he was so excited
about the yurt and living outdoors with
no ac i had to get ready for this
wedding
in a yurt
with no ac in the middle of summer
that just held the heat in the yurt and
i'm sweating through my makeup as i'm
applying it
and i was like
this is making him so happy you know and
then like
and he loves that kind of shit and i
never really go like terrorizing you
yeah pranks he loves pranking you yes he
loves he loves to talk about yourself
okay you love pranks so much i'm just
gonna let you have this one he's like
we're gonna live outside tonight and i'm
like i don't wanna i don't wanna live
outside ever um
like we have the option of living inside
it's so funny we we are inside people we
have a house
we have a roof we have all the things we
need we have electricity and he's like
let's try it without yeah no no no no no
of so much fun and i just go i say no to
this so much oh god he's going to be one
of those when you get pregnant he's not
going to want to know the gender
oh yeah see one of those i want to do it
the hard way he
i don't think he does he do mud runs no
but he is like spartan race he's from
seattle so he's like let's go in the
mountains let's do these things together
that mean something to me you're like i
bleed bears want to eat me right
right and i'm also like my life's been
kind of hard yeah yeah yeah i don't
really want to like challenge my
survival because i already feel i hate
that like it's a lot to just be alive
that is i mean to me
that is like the dividing
when i meet someone that just has not
had adversity in their life in any way i
just i'm not sure how to attune to them
i also get kind of bored
uh but
when people are like i just want to do
something every day that scares me i'm
like you need a boyfriend who hits you
i'm like dude just just once i'd like to
do something once
in any day that i'm not scared of yeah i
would love that yeah i'm like really
nice lose a treasured loved one
or find a domestic abuser
what would possibly scare me and to have
no to have to live outside
like the idea that it's like i could
just text anyone in my phone yeah and
he'll be terrified right
i don't know why um i don't know why he
loves this shit danger is not thrilling
to you because you've had so much of
that
like risk and listen listen my sister
died but she did die in a hot tub which
is a nice place to die so it's not like
she got uh
it's there's that's a dream way to die
for some people so i'm not gonna say
it's been the toughest life it's not the
victim olympics i'm just saying that's
it's there's been some times where i've
like it's been rough it is such a i mean
look and when you watch the special and
watch the way that she
you know does this joke and such a
it's such a
tight rope
ballet it's like this verbal ballet and
um
it is so funny how
how long you let the audience picture
your sister dead and then it's like in a
hot tub and you're like oh fuck like i
i'm so sorry that i'm laughing at this
but there's i don't know
yeah
it's it's such a tricky one yeah i think
it was it was such a long time before i
was able to really
talk about that on stage in a way that
didn't end in me just
being like i just took comedy away from
everybody yeah but right like i just i
just ruined the show yeah you know and
that happened a lot of times yeah
and i was just like i don't give a shit
thank you for letting me share the wrong
room yes just open my
that is such a wildly like
comedic thing within something that is
so beyond tragic was that at all
in terms of
being a comedian like is there any
oh this is when i started laughing about
tragic stuff or was it way before that
it was way before that oh interesting i
started laughing about tragic shit even
as a kid because i just
um
i don't know it just makes me laugh i
just think it's i don't i think things
got way funnier to me
uh after she died like things got way
like the worst thing happening
made me feel less alone you know like
the
the tragedy
was the thing that made me laugh until
till this day you give me some sad news
my first reaction is gonna be
yeah
you know the emotional dyslexia of it
yeah and i and i don't i don't know why
that is but it is like
uh
it's just the thing that makes me laugh
we're all just coping and like i think
when uh and i'm so glad we uh have
talked for this long without talking
about negative comments too much um uh
because again comedians it's like
you had a hundred good ones and one bad
one and you're gonna talk about it on
podcast for seven hours like jesus
christ it's like right now it's just
it's getting so old this whole thing
where comedians like my first amendment
free speech it's like okay so you're
allowed to have free speech but no one's
allowed to write you're not like why
can't they have everyone should be able
to have it you know what i'm saying like
this is part of the deal and like you
know just be prepared to deal with yeah
if you want everybody to say what they
want you didn't i if someone had come to
us when we were 18 or whatever and like
what is your dream i'm going to be a
stand-up comedian well what if only
half the people like you they're great
yeah i'll take that yeah and in order to
have a huge career you only need a
million people basically to come see
your shows in the united states to make
like 20 million you don't need that many
people to like you yeah i'm saying to be
a super success you don't need to have
everybody you know but this idea this
entitlement that everyone needs to like
what i do it's just kind of like that to
me is it's taking me a long time to go
like
think about things that everybody likes
i mean it's is there i won't beyonce if
you look at
the things trending in netflix like the
top trending shows yeah
it's if you click on any of those things
they're trash
they're like from the 60s for the most
part they are
garbage they're like women in corsets
please yeah and i'm like
and and this is just for the stuff that
netflix is showing me yeah so i know
that all of it is like supposed to be
something i like yeah and i'm like this
is
like
somebody's got a brain injury yeah and
he's pitching this shit and people are
like we love it you know so i think
about that shit where i'm like everybody
likes this and it's garbage yeah and one
of the shows everybody like csi every
episode's about murdering hookers like
every episode is about getting the dna
out of the strippers vagina i'm just
like okay this is
i'm okay if not everybody likes me it's
so funny that that's such a popular show
and yet people are like why don't you
report it
it's like i don't know because i have to
like return my pussy to the station and
have it inspected like a rental car
when it was just already
i mean by the way like i you just had a
stranger in it and now you need to like
take a little shower yeah before you
came in there's no dna in here yes sorry
the tears washed it away yeah
sorry the sobbing crying
i always think about i'm like
yeah you're just asking i don't know
they're like the only way that we can
find out who did this is by also
inserting ourselves into you without
your consent i'm like jesus christ
there's got to be another way to do this
yeah no no no no no we just have to
scoop out the cum well it's not in there
anymore why not why didn't you just do a
kegel the whole way to the station yeah
you should have held the hair in oh
sorry
sorry i just didn't want to get the
rapist sperm in my ovaries i thought it
might be good to try it out
sorry or i
wasn't thinking anything because i've
been sobbing and the quaalude just wore
off right
it was fine there was this you talked
about the gift of fear on something and
uh it's a book i talk about constantly
i'm obsessed with yeah but there was
this you know uh uh uh gavin de becker
wrote it about you know our intuition
and how we've sort of been um
uh trained to ignore training to ignore
or minimize uh that we've internalized
other people's narratives of us of i'm
just being dramatic or i'm probably
overblowing this or i'm probably just
being sensitive yeah you know um
especially if men are chivalrous or do
things that are ostensibly helpful
carrying your groceries to the car
opening the door for you we're like well
they're so nice
a murderer would never do that right
it's not like that's what ted bundy did
or anything you know yeah it's like
every murder documentaries he helped her
to her car right he had a broken arm and
were like
yeah um what do you mean i'm in a room
i'm in a rom-com right and uh
oh and there was a statistic that was um
it was like 99 of women
that after they were assaulted by a
stranger
uh in the exit interview or whatever you
would call it when they got fired from
being a good woman whatever that thing
is called the post interview right 99 of
them said i knew there was something off
about that guy yeah like i knew it yeah
they all said if i really go back and i
think what my gut was telling me
about this person and it's true every
person that's ever fucked me over
every person that's ever yeah in my gut
i
i went
uh
i don't know about this person which is
what we do with drugs alcohol everything
ah fuck it so so i think there's
something so liberating about going i
knew there was something wrong about
that person okay i was right what's
going on with me that i ignored that
instinct and kept going or like did i
want to be in a dangerous situation do i
get off on danger or auditioning for
other people's approval i don't have to
blame that person that person just got
to show me the thing i need to work on
yeah and i can release that person and
thank them and move on instead of going
fucked up person like figure out why you
were attracted that person in the first
place ignore them and their behavior
yeah why were you that's why i think
that every self-help book
every like program everything it can all
kind of
it all boils down to there's nothing
wrong with you trust yourself you're
perfect as you are you deserve love yeah
because you exist and that's it and
nothing's happening to you it's
happening for you yeah if you ca that's
the only way to move through life like
even if you have to fake it to make it
it's like everything is happening for
your benefit if you can't think of
things i mean that's basically what the
third step is of 12-step programs
everything's happening exactly as it
should and
you know that is uh you know scar tissue
is stronger than regular tissue like
when you get injured or hurt like you
actually are stronger later and better
equipped you know for the world and
the gratitude of like oh something bad
happened that means it's over now right
i'm saying like i think sometimes it's
so hard to go like all these bad things
happen and you just identify as all
these bad things that happened to you
but the more bad things that happened to
you statistically the less bad things
that are going to happen to you so there
should be you know it's just a matter of
like hacking your brain to just um
change your perception and we say in a
program it's a disease of perception
you're perceiving that everything is
like everyone's trying to fuck you over
and everybody hates you or you're
perceiving that like i'm so much funnier
when i'm on cocaine or i'm so much more
i'm so much more outgoing when i drink
like those are all perceptions that are
just dead wrong yeah you're just wrong
right but there's something so cool
about being wrong you're like oh great
i'm wrong yeah at least i know the truth
i don't care what the truth is like
there's something so um
freeing about that um okay i have kept
you a wild amount of time uh because i'm
obsessed with you this has been so funny
i love i i love your brain and your mind
and i think everyone should just hear
you talk as long as possible something
so sweet thank you
you're so sweet no seriously i
you were the first comic that i watched
where i was like i want to be like her
i want to be like her you know like i
was like
i and not just on stage i meant like in
your life like i was like she's a great
joke writer
she knows how to make money she knows
how to live and she and she
she stays focused on herself in the
right ways
and i i always like
looked up to you in that way where i was
like this is fucking incred and i
remember tweeting it at you at one point
and you retweeted it and i was like i'm
gonna die i'm gonna die and it was very
very new and you would never remember it
but it was like something about how like
i want whitney cummings like horse money
and uh and you retweeted it and i was
like uh and it really meant a lot to you
probably didn't know i was a comment i
did no i definitely did
and i'm thinking about it and that was
at a time where i was i realized i think
i was getting a lot of negativity from
whatever the internet before i sort of
was able to process that and be able to
um
uh sort of hack my brain to take any
kind of negativity on the internet as a
positive like there's no way for it to
hurt my feelings anymore just because of
the way that i've tried to like judo it
in my head so for me uh i finally am
able to but at the time i don't think i
did and i was feeling a lot of shame i
think in that time for having been
successful financially it's like
everyone's burned with me it's like
wouldn't so richmond and it's like
it was just like it's just such a weird
thing because i think i was so insecure
because for the longest time people
would always say i'm ambitious that was
like the big dig on me is like she's so
ambitious like yeah i'm poor
like like what do you talk yeah i don't
have a trust fund to fall back like i
don't what do you mean i'm ambitious i'm
just trying trying hard and that was
kind of looked down upon at the time so
then
when that when people got obsessed with
the fact that i had money or that the
syndication that deal became public and
people i mean emily knows i'm going
broke um every day
but uh
i
think i was like needed to go like no
i'm gonna be proud of this because i
don't want any women or younger women to
think you have to be embarrassed that
you
no i loved it god a lot and i really was
like yeah fuck yeah it's like it it's so
important well because people i just
want this and i want respect you want to
be famous you want to be rich just say
it it's okay of course i want to be
respected of course i want to like have
all these but stop pretending that you
don't want money and because it is a way
that we limit ourselves and it's some
bullshit shame that if anyone needs you
to not want to earn money
get them out of your life yeah that
shouldn't be embarrassing that shouldn't
be shameful right
every
i i just i love that you said i want
money yeah yes yeah just say it like
there was a tweet sorry last thing i'll
say i know i went on a rant but
uh someone tweeted and i'll find the
actual person and we'll credit them but
um i put her on my stories it said um
you know i'm a gen z person and people
are always telling me you know uh am i
afraid of out earning my boyfriend and
emasculating him and she just uh and
then she wrote no i'm not give me money
i do not yeah i'm not worried about that
no i don't give a shit that's some
boomer shit yeah i don't give a shit
like if we have a family and i'm making
more money than you
and you have a problem with it you're
ruining your life that's right because
i'm not i don't give a fuck yeah like
yeah if you want to know that escalates
you that's between you and your dad like
that's not my problem yeah you know so
so i
i appreciated that and i um
and that meant a lot to me
that it was like another comic was like
i want money yeah like this like her i'm
like yes yeah like that is like that was
just so gangster to me and um
and uh and i've always wanted to get to
know you better and i've always been
just so um
impressed by by you and and your grace
and your
clarity
your clarity and
you're also just freaking hilarious
that's the same whiskey fists
not whiskey feels right whiskey fists on
youtube it's hilarious it's brilliant uh
your podcast with your husband is
called i just had to remember
it's find your beach seriously the
compliment is just like i'm letting it
wash over me a little bit um yeah our
podcast is called find your beach it's
available wherever you get your podca
podcasts
and it's so it's there's something to be
so bad but my water broke so long ago
and then also follow rosebot on twitter
hilarious instagram all of it um rosebud
baker on both of those yeah uh i am
super awkwardly um
as if now it's getting awkward don't
write elephants love you guys rosebud
baker don't write elephants